um
[Music]
i have with me david pakman he is a
progressive host
an executive producer of the
nationally syndicated radio and tv
program the david pacman show
and i wanted to talk to david pacman
he is a beta male 1
david patman
he is
david pacman
he is a baby
[Music]
[Music]
can you remind the audience when you
talk about being a beta male and being
an alpha male what what are we talking
about here
there are males most men today yeah male
1 they think and act like a woman
they're emotional
they are mentally off they have no logic
and that's a baby male they go along
with homosexuality hold on but whoa whoa
jesse well we gotta that's a lot
that's a lot hang on agree with
everything that's raw abortion they
think and act just like a woman a beta
male died but not
doesn't because he's a logical thinking
and they're controlled by the darkness
of david pacman
he is a baby
[Music]
david packman
he
[Music]
david patman he is a beta male 1
[Music]
david patman
he is a man
of
david pakman
he
is david pacman
he is a baby
david you're not here to communicate i
really appreciate you coming on i'm
going to let you go it's a waste of time
to talk to you we're not communicating
you're actually like because you're
asking bizarre questions you're actually
like you're idiot and you're wasting my
time i appreciate that
all right thank you
goodbye goodbye
[Music]
look at that
look at that look at that that is why
who thinks he's smarter than you why who
thinks he's smarter than you why who
thinks he's smarter than you
this
is look at that
look at that look at that man's a loser
pac-man's a loser pac-man's a loser
pac-man's a loser
this is
[Music]
[Music]
this
jones has fake callers jones has fake
callers jones has fake collars this is
[Music]
trump was doing this with his personal
toilet
toilets
and showers elements of bathrooms
10 times 15 times
elements of bathrooms
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elements of bathrooms
10 times
[Music]
trump's white house toilet
would be clogged clogged
[Music]
with documents that donald trump was
flushing down the toilet
[Music]
is this the explanation is this the
explanation
big massive
[Music]
ten times
[Music]
my bags are mangoes mangos
[Music]
i love mangoes too
okay
now that we are up under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now cost 11.
and 99
that seems like a pretty good deal a bag
of mangoes mango aren't measures like
reebok seeds
that's it
eight or 11 bucks
[Music]
bring
[Music]
[Music]
the wisconsin crowd identifying with the
mangoes
forcefully affected the american people
don't want me to be healthy
healthy
want me to be healthy
[Music]
welcome everybody uh what an
introduction uh we have maybe the
biggest
news day in a very long time
we are monitoring day one of cpac as i
told you guys i was scheduled to start
cpac coverage today and we're doing it
the first speech that we're going to be
covering is in about 45 minutes that
were will be manic
kimberly gilfoyle's speech the best is
yet to come right
but
we also may be within just hours western
allies believe we may be hours
from kiev
falling to putin
putin's got himself a country he's
invaded a country and he's taking it uh
we we now are learning that we may be
within just hours of that
western allies see keeve falling to
russian army
within
hours
official says ukraine's air defenses
have been eliminated
putin may plan to replace ukraine's
leader with a puppet regime
folks
the people who for weeks have been
minimizing the threat saying oh he's
he's not going to invade
this is biden's fear-mongering because
biden's bloodthirsty
globalist
internationalist trotsky okay anyway um
we may be hours
from keeve falling to putin
and uh if and when that happens
if and when that happens
we will then
figure out what's next
and what putin's plan is but we are
monitoring multiple feeds
interestingly from the standpoint of
stocks
what started out as the worst day in
like forever
somehow stocks clawed their way back to
gains in the s p and the nazdag as trump
calls it uh 400 points up on the nasdag
at this point who the hell knows what's
going on
it's all crazy okay it's all crazy in
addition to all of this
gensake is about to do a press briefing
during which i can only assume she's
going to get all sorts of nasty
questions so we're monitoring all of it
settle in we're going to be here for
some hours at least five this will be at
least a five minute long stream but
probably more like hours because we have
all sorts of stuff ted cruz will be
speaking to cpac a little bit later uh
it's just there's so so so much going on
uh so we're gonna monitor that we're
also monitoring other news chernobyl has
been seized russian soldiers have now
occupied the former nuclear power plant
according to keeve they've taken that
it's a full-scale invasion
uh we are monitoring video in kiev to
see what is going on it's now
10 39 p.m there
i don't know what this is i don't even
know how the this is the this is an
archive of the pat mcafee show i don't
even know what that i don't know how
that got on there um
joe biden earlier announcing more severe
sanctions against russia and we are
monitoring cpac as well we have multiple
angles on cpac here as you can see uh we
have this angle where you see cowboy hat
guy from this angle you don't see cowboy
hat guy and then we also have the
official uh american conservative union
feed so we are monitoring all of it
absolutely all of it
uh i don't even know where else to start
because there's so much going on
uh let me read a few super chats mark
allen says thank reason for david pakman
this is therapy thank you mark
and cyrus palmer says i love the alex
jones impression globalished
internationalist trotskyite socialists
unlike obama trudeau macron
and the rest of these zio beasts
right pac-man's a loser oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves is bad that is a freaking
predator right there okay very very good
so um that that's that's where we are
that's where we are right now you might
notice above my head we have a new
coupon code and it is cpac trash cpac
trash
and i want to welcome jason irvine
as well as brenton smith who just signed
up on my website uh yeah first person to
use the code cpac trash gets a free item
from my store that i'll go with it sure
nobody's used it yet
also want to say thank you over on
twitch to caveman dr boshimonos
tbs zero cool jen here gifting two subs
onions savvy lemons and beth graham
everybody signing up today very very
much appreciate now if you guys want to
talk about nuclear
never
never uh um
never composting
trash
i will point you to tulsi gabbard's
tweets
everything she has been tweeting has
been
radioactive trash look at this one
warmongers have got what they wanted
firmly established new cold war
guaranteed trillions for the power elite
including the military industrial
security complex and mainstream media um
what
what what
what are you talking about tulsi
it might not shock you that the last
real leftist tulsi gabbard
is speaking at cpac
[Laughter]
yeah
yeah
uh remember guys she's
against war
and
against regime change
okay
yeah
super chats are just pouring in here
a gremlin says on a lighter note here's
an anagram to celebrate the release of
truth social trump social website we
promise it's a bs cult well done david
sir what is whitney's strategy for peace
in the ukraine well it's actually just
ukraine
um here's the latest from whitney
because you asked
david i want to talk to you about your
genetics which is your foolish
and
ukrainian
and hebrew
okay so there is whitney solving all
geopolitical problems here's something
interesting check take a look at this
guys this is you might find this
fascinating
this is interesting
earlier today
i highlighted
a tv
from hold on where is this
i highlighted a tweet
from an individual named farren franzak
who tweeted about nine days ago
y'all gonna feel really dumb
when russia never quote
invades
and i highlighted this and i said i feel
really dumb
but not for this reason
and this is an individual who is a host
on rt america
which is
okay it's it's russian state media it
turns out that farron is in our audience
and she is owning up to
her mistake
i hope rt doesn't fire her
guys
this was deserves respect okay
farron is here with a 10 super chat
and says hi david i'm the news anchor
you retweeted
wanted to tell you i was wrong
many of us were very wrong
we're all in shock
praying for those in ukraine i'm also a
subscriber appreciate your show
when people own up to their mistakes
we welcome that we don't ridicule people
for saying i was wrong we say
great job now
i don't know if this view is going to be
welcomed on rt america
i'm not saying it is and i'm not saying
it isn't but we welcome truth
and good for farren
uh
for saying this
i hope you are not fired
okay
um
what else did i have we were on we were
on tulsi
uh yeah okay so anyway toolsie now i do
want to say something i want to i do
need to let you guys know about
something that's very ugly
the tulsi people
are trying to cancel me and they're
trying to to hurt us financially
okay
here is uh and i confirmed that this is
you know how we have these unsubscribed
trolls who are like david that's it now
i'm unsubscribing and then i look and
it's like you've never been subscribed
okay this is not one of those cases
i just received an email today
hold on what am i doing
what am i even looking at here here we
go
robert wrote to me
and said this is a tool c unsub
dear david
i have unsubscribed from your show
because you revealed your are tribal
you look for labels and you follow the
liberal official narrative
tulsi gabbard speaks to citizens of all
labels calling us to remember our common
ground is far greater than our pet
peeves
wake up
robert
who canceled his membership
okay
now
i say good riddance to robert
if you're looking for alt-left
trash
i'm guessing there are places where you
can find
okay so robert you can go but the point
is
there are people who are not doing what
farron fr franzak did which is say i was
wrong
there's people who are doubling down
okay
that's why with tulsi speaking at cpac
today we have the coupon code cpac trash
which you can use to sign up on our
website
my hope is
20 people
replace robert
in membership ranks
and
then we can say thanks to robert for
growing our level of support
uh we are monitoring everything live
here we are at uh
at cpac we're gonna look for another
tranche of members as people like to say
we're also monitoring uh
we're monitoring gensake there's just so
much so much happening today okay other
super chats coming in
uh hard not to see parallels between
what's going on now in the 30s an
unhinged dictator taking whatever he
wants with hollow threats coming from
the nation supposed to be defending
against him sad times
i hate to say it but that is that is
true
that is true
thanks to nikki k shreds
corrosive dog and caveman doctor for the
twitch prime subscriptions also
we have just absolutely
huge dumps of memberships dumps
uh coming in on the website thanks to
aaron cosell
who is the first person to use the
coupon code cpac trash aaron you've got
yourself a free item from my online
store email info davidpakman.com to
collect on that aaron cosell is a new
member tagger wilson is a new member
welcome to justin mckinley luis alvarez
kelly shaughnessy chris killness
bae valiquette
and kyle w
all subscribing on my website
uh putting us at 20
and it is just the beginning of what i
trust will be
quite a long day today now while we have
time
let's just go through
some of the other material okay so cpac
feed let me just see everything i have
cpac stage is dark right now
rsbn cpac feed
another cpac feed
uh coverage of what's going on in
ukraine
we may soon be the be targeted by
russian cyber attacks i think it is
important to mention i just putting that
out there if we are taken down due to a
cyber attack if this stream is taken
down
i will do what i can
to get a hot spot going on my phone and
to get right back on
that's that's my promise to you
monitoring keeve
where it is now closing in on
11 pm eastern uh monitoring euro news
and what's going on
um
where is this this is
paris the ukraine looks like it's is it
the russian or ukrainian embassy in
paris france monitoring that
gensake about to speak
um
the big news is western allies see kiev
falling to the russian army within hours
putin may have
taken stolen himself a country in just
about 24 hours
we're monitoring that
stocks soon to close 10 minutes left and
what started as a disastrous trading day
has turned positive is this an
inspirational sign of the resiliency of
the american economy is it just
speculation is it the so-called dead cat
bounce i don't pretend to know
i don't time the market
i don't say oh here's a good time to buy
sell
i just buy
i buy buy buy buy
many people would have thought today was
going to be a crash and it started that
way
the market has turned positive
okay
next
by the way
oh that you have to see this
here's a russian
journalist saying
there's no invasion of ukraine happening
guys there's just no invasion
there's no invasion happening what the
russian troops are doing
well first of all let's uh you know
let's get one thing straight uh you're
saying troops however there has not been
any proof of actual troops going into
ukraine well all of the videos including
the russian troops who took an airport
and the russian troops who took
chernobyl and the tanks with the russian
troops and
other than that we don't really have
evidence of any russians in ukraine and
the ministry of defense has stated
clearly that this operation which you
cannot truly classify as an invasion
because again there are no troops on the
ground right has been i mean other than
all the troops on the ground including
the ones
in this video
entering i believe this was the vid i
don't remember if this was the video of
russian troops entering via belarus or
crimea
but in any case i love the side-by-side
targeting
military targets within ukraine so we're
talking airfields we're talking air
defense systems we're talking
the anchor is just brilliant like
you're kidding right i mean you're not
you're not being serious are you not an
innovation i want to ask you why this is
not an invasion what we're seeing now in
ukraine
of
the definition of the word invasion
what do you know
i'm not playing a game with you tatiana
i'm asking you how on earth can you
justify
what we're seeing now there's not an
invasion you call yourself a reporter
answer the question why is this not an
invasion what's that what's that the
justification there in moscow
well again an invasion would actually
require for russian troops to go into
ukraine which they did they have not
those are precision strikes that being
that are being carried out from russian
territory and they're only targeting
military targets
uh as for justification of the operation
i believe that here's video of the
russian troops president has actually
been very clear so far
uh he recognized the independence of the
two republics on monday which is
completely illegitimate and what you're
showing now those uh unfortunately the
pictures that cannot be verified that
those are troops these are all totally
unverified images i mean they've been
verified by other news outlets but she
hasn't verified them into ukraine
okay so there's a journalist guys that
was a journalist um here is steve bannon
steve barron bannon and eric prince from
uh formerly known as blackwater
mercenary group does anybody remember
eric blackwater has been renamed two or
three times do you guys remember what
it's called i don't it doesn't even
matter formerly of blackwater who the
hell knows what it's called now here's
their explanation that's and the reason
that putin ain't woke
he is anti-woke to russians people still
know which bathroom to use right guys
support the violation of ukrainian
sovereignty and borders
because putin is anti-trans the the
elements of bathrooms elements of
bathrooms as organized in russia
are pleasing to eric prince therefore
support an invasion of a sovereign
country
they know how many how many genders are
there in russia two okay that's all
sudden that's that's that's not that's
not they don't have the flags they don't
have the pride flags outside on their on
their they don't have boys it's funny
how the people who are like we really
need trump to keep us out of wars we
really need him to do it because war is
the worst thing
but an invasion over
bathrooms i mean you know come on
elements of bathrooms he's swimming in
girls
uh college swim meets how backward it's
it's how embarrassing how savage how
medieval
how medieval this is why this whole
thing's a scam it's a total and complete
scam yep so very very sick individuals
as you can see uh oh hold on the
guilfoyle speech we're live
and not too long ago
let's get a better better here we go air
shelves biden
[Applause]
honestly
junior's making me ride my bicycle
around town because we can't afford the
gas at this point i mean come on
[Applause]
but we can
and we will make change in this country
in fact we must because there are
americans hard-working americans that
are struggling to provide for their
families
and not too long ago they actually had
more discretionary spending and choice
and cash in their pockets because
president trump said you know better
what to do with your hard-earned money
than the tax and spend liberals in
washington d.c
[Music]
and now we have illegal aliens
crossing the border and possibly the
highest numbers that we have ever seen
and you heard the words of the fearless
border patrol agent as he spoke so
eloquently and with emotion and grace
about what he has seen at the border
about the sacrifices and the way that
this administration the country has
turned its back on ice on border patrol
agents that are putting it on the line
every single day and night and we stand
and we salute them for their courage and
their sacrifice to this country what is
she talking about
forget miley cyrus the new wrecking ball
is joe biden and just under here he's
already tried wrecked this country so
what do you say if we give joe biden a
pink slip and get him out of here not a
joke
and take kamala harris with you while
you're at it that's a bunch of money
pelosi with you while you're at it and
schumer and aoc and the whole group of
them
really inspiring speaker
[Applause]
and i yeah and janey too where's harriet
hagenman we're going to get rid of her
as well i love it harriet hageman great
candidate in wyoming
so biden and the radical democrats have
managed and i kid you not to put america
last it's like very obvious they're
playing for the other team with every
single decision
all the while trying to destroy
president trump's historic achievements
which are what that's why we have to
take it back
because president trump created the best
economy our nation has ever seen
he pushed petty politics aside and did
what was best for the american people
remember the american people the people
in this country
we apologize to no one for putting
america first that's what a true leader
does he stands for each and every one of
us
meanwhile
joe biden canceled the keystone pipeline
causing oil prices to soar and
destroying thousand american jobs in the
process
and shortly after he canceled the
keystone xl pipeline he served putin
a gift on a silver platter here you go
vlad
he approved russia's nordstream 2
pipeline can you believe this this is
what i'm talking about will she mention
it's since been canceled due to the
invasion will she mention it guys jersey
not the russia first jersey not the
china first jersey and stop exporting
the american dream
because joe biden has fundamentally
destroyed this country in record order
and including our border because the
protectors of our border national
security are so important there's a
story that really strikes me especially
with what we've heard today in the panel
that mercedes did
biden's dhs secretary marcus recently
told our border patrol quote i know the
policies of this administration are
particularly popular with u.s customs
and border protection but that's the
reality so let's see what we can do
within that framework i mean can you
believe it talk about taking an a
one border patrol agent even reportedly
turned his back on mayorkas that's
courage that's being american and
standing up for what you believe in
sounds kind of dumb actually border
patrol agent is a hero for standing up
and being fearless for what's right
i want to ask you here today all
patriotic americans across this country
stand up for what you believe in be that
border patrol agent use your first
amendment rights to fight back against
the democrat incompetence that we are
seeing throughout the country
show up show up in record numbers to
peacefully protest when democrat
officials attempt to destroy the
sanctity of the united states
constitution
show up to school board meetings when
they try to indoctrinate our nation's
children
vote in midterm elections this year to
put america first fearless republicans
back in office and in the majority
that's a bunch of
first step to success in taking back
this great country
ladies and gentlemen every election
matters whether we're talking about the
school board mayoral races and even
control of congress i encourage i
implore you to run for office yourself
volunteer for races and most importantly
vote
it is so important for us to fight back
justice are working overtime to strip us
of our freedoms take a look at what's
happened on social media in recent years
almost every big tech platform has
banned conservatives and republicans for
their political beliefs no they banned
people for disinformation media platform
banned president trump last year
if the sitting president at the time of
the united states can be banned on
social media no one is safe well yeah
the point is anyone can be banned if
they break the rules that seems like a
great point to me in the wrong opinions
or for even promoting the idea of free
expression
just look at what happened to hong kong
china cracked down on them and jailed
people simply simply for wanting
the ability and the freedom to express
their opinion the freedoms that we enjoy
in this country but unfortunately our
freedoms
our freedoms are now at that same risk
thanks to big tech and to the liberal
woke leftists
what's the difference between being
punished in china for having the wrong
opinions and big tech companies
silencing you for daring to have
conservative beliefs
sadly now
there is no now of course no one's been
silenced for being conservative people
have been banned when they violate the
terms of service of platforms and it
just so happens the vast majority of the
inciting of violence and the vast
majority of the kova disinformation is
coming from the right side of silicon
valley and considering that social media
is now the public sphere of discussion
in the 21st century they can completely
silence you
just like they try to silence president
trump
good luck right you can't shut him down
okay we are at real risk for losing our
first amendment rights and most
importantly our freedom of expression
we do a great disservice to the men and
women did that counter say she only had
seven seconds left did you guys see that
that was weird right that they fought
for that families have sacrificed for
that's why we're here at cpac today to
stand up for what we believe in for what
you believe in your family and your
children we can fight back
you can fight back twitter and facebook
aren't the be all and all
that's right we have other platforms now
we have president trump's new truth
social sign up jump over and enjoy the
freedom of expression
we love it where free speech lives
president trump had to fix that too good
god
we must support freedom-loving
alternatives if we want to protect our
rights that are ingrained in the
constitution and we also need our
republican lawmakers to use their power
to hold these anti-american big tech
companies accountable
no more rhinos how about some real
fighters like president trump
in the congress and in the senate and
guess what back in the oval office
and the same goes for our education
system are you so tired of public
schools indoctrinating young children
i know that i am and i'm sure many of
you had to suffer through it yourselves
rather than teach our nation's children
our future the skills they need to
succeed in life and in the real world
they are teaching our children critical
race theory ah teaching our children to
be ashamed of who they are whatever it
is they were born the color of their
skin and making them apologists for
history it is shameful
this type of thing does not happen in
president trump's america she's right my
teachers would always tell me i should
be really embarrassed that i'm male like
martin luther king fought for oh no oh
no but it gets worse because public
schools are teaching our children as
young as kindergarten that they can
choose their gender at will they are
teaching our children that doctors are
wrong and that we are not the gender
that we were born with
i find it disturbing what's happening to
our nation's children as a mother of a
15 year old i speak up i am vocal some
of them are being kept home for radical
right wing homeschooling i feel terrible
for a lot of these kids your children
and for your family
and the media is complicit for refusing
to cover it
i ask you today most especially to fight
for our children they are worth it and
they deserve your voice and your
strength and be that example of
leadership and courage
but the american people are waking up
and a red wave is coming do you all feel
it
[Music]
right
and like i said when republicans retake
congress with america first candidates
later this year the first thing they
need to do
is stop joe biden's far left woke agenda
dead in its track
the what now kimberly
and as a a wise man once said
everything woke turns to
[Applause]
yep in spanish we say
mexico genius that trump i love him
let's stop george soros funded da's and
judges across this country
yeah don't allow biden to pass so-called
bipartisan legislation where democrats
get everything they want and republicans
yet nothing that's why we need majority
leaders and notice that when republicans
are in power and they pass something
with like two democrats they cheer that
it's bipartisan
when democrats are in power and pass
something with two six or thirteen
republicans they go it's not really
bipartisan those aren't even real
republicans they love to say time
opportunity to change the course we are
at the point of no return and it is up
to all of you to vote and ensure
republicans witness the biggest land
side in our nation's history later this
year
i know it is possible i believe it is
possible we can feel the tides turning
and in 2022 the american people will
retake congress and we will retire nancy
pelosi and take the gavel right out of
her hands the best is yet
to
come and send her back to san francisco
where she can wreck that some more
democrats that we will no longer we will
never allow them
no longer to radically transform america
in their far left woke image and as
president trump said this is just the
start the maga movement is alive and
well we will show the democrats
firsthand that elections have
consequences when we win a record number
of seats in the midterms and that is
just step one oh boy step two is
reclaiming the white house and returning
president trump to the oval office oh
god they're starting with it
i pray about this
pray harder
and i am confident that if we are lucky
to have president trump make that
sacrifice again that he will defeat joe
biden for a second time
[Applause]
i mean technically if he won last time
then he's not eligible to run again you
can't be pre you can't win three times
make america great again
we will fix the economy we will secure
our borders and strengthen our national
security and we will be respected on the
world stage is she gonna do the line you
think we will recreate the jobs that joe
biden destroyed and much more if you
thought the first four years were great
you ain't seen nothing yet
but this change
this movement
starts with you the american people you
must speak up you must show up and most
importantly you must vote
in
2016
we saw then candidate donald trump
defeat hillary clinton in the biggest
political upset our nation has ever seen
until biden beat trump she wants some
more come and get it hillary
and that was thanks to all of you
turning out to vote making your voices
heard
now it is time to make
history once again who's ready for it
and we will ban men
ladies and gentlemen and patriots and
great lovers of liberty and freedom one
request for you today oh no fight
fight
fight for your future fight for your
children fight for your freedoms and
fight for this country for america the
greatest
nation on earth you are the most
powerful force in this country and i
know that we can overcome the far left
woke democrats that joe biden has been
enabling and empowering
the silent majority will be silent no
more and together we will
make america great again
god bless you cpac
god bless america god bless president
trump
[Music]
there she goes
[Music]
wow
so there is kimberly guilfoyle the next
speaker man this is fun isn't it i mean
obviously this is indicative of
extremely serious downfall of society
but what a great day to be with you guys
next is going to be the wrongest man in
the world on the pandemic alex berenson
so just so people understand the agenda
today
we're standing by for jen saki
the latest report is western allies
believe putin may be hours from taking
keeve he's about to take ukraine and he
may install a puppet government
putin's just he took a country okay and
we are standing by
uh potentially just hours from that
in the meantime cpac continues and we're
going to hear from jen saki in a bit in
terms of the agenda alex berenson is
next
after that there's going gonna be some
kind of uh
panel i guess i don't even i don't even
really know and then later we're gonna
hear from
wayne lapierre the ceo of the nra that
should be a pretty corrosive speech
then we'll hear from senator ted cruz
which will just be absolutely vile and
then the evening will end with senator
josh hawley so that's the agenda today
um for cpac
uh tomorrow
there are other speakers and then
saturday i'll be live with you guys for
the um uh president what was that guy's
name trump then he went donald trump
yeah donald trump yeah anyways uh prompt
will be speaking on saturday and we will
be live with that and i'm not i'm not
going to stream sunday sunday's kind of
a trash day it's just don jr seeking
approval from his father um so i'm not
even going to bother on on sunday we're
we're not going to cover it
okay so we are standing by here for gen
saki let me hear some of the the things
you guys have to say before i do that i
want to make sure i'm thanking everybody
who is supporting us today that includes
and we have some pretty big things
happening here
uh
okay wait i want to say thank you to
some of these people i thanked already
okay
levin
emmy thomas
emmy thomas gifted five subscriptions
chubbles
said a dragon
symbolic gamer the automatic man
blueberry babe gifted two
littlefinger x and sj babe
um that's 11 putting us at 31 also be
kimberly puts us at 32.
over on our website i want to say thanks
to jean van wick
as well as arielle finberg who signed up
with our new coupon code cpac trash
cpac trash
and just if people miss this
the toolsies have started to unsubscribe
robert wrote in saying i've unsubscribed
you because you don't like tulsi um so
tulsi speaking at cpac i'm not gonna
strong-arm anybody but it would be a
great day to get a membership at
jointpakman.com and you can use that
coupon code cpac trash to fight directly
against that dude um okay
let's see we're still waiting for
gensake we're monitoring cpac
it's just okay so this one we're going
to close
and we'll really just stick with this
and we're of course monitoring the
situation in uh in ukraine
and russia as well where things are not
looking
particularly good andrew asks whether i
like the pat mcafee show i've only seen
those wacky episodes where aaron rodgers
said he got medical advice from joe
rogan
felix says yo cpac is actually insane i
know
it's it's completely bonkers
completely and totally bonkers
um one well look at this guy that's a
serious spread this is the last guy you
want to be next to on the subway look at
this guy here
man you do not want to be near him uh
yeah if in case you guys were wondering
yesterday
literally as putin started bombing keeve
trump doubled down
at mar-a-lago about just how impressed
he is with putin trump said he's smart i
mean he's taken over a country
for two dollars worth of sanctions i'd
say that's pretty smart smart guy
he's taking over a country of really a
vast
vast
location a great
piece of land it's horrific real estate
if you're looking for a building lot i
mean what the value putin is getting
from ukraine is just unbelievable
and just walking right in this would
have never happened ever in a million
years would have never happened and i
know very well i know
probably almost as well as i know
anybody in this room other than dr
romney doc ronnie knows me who is that
right
so putin really quite quite smitten
uh
i mean trump quite smitten with putin
uh oh man what what an insane insane
situation
um
[Music]
okay
people wondering what uh we already
heard one voicemail from whitney about
what she thinks about all of this i
guess i'll do one more
uh let's see
so it's saying here that um putin is
saying that he's going to hold um russia
accountable
but i don't really understand because
it's like not really our area it was
taken during the holocaust so
i mean like
you have to give back all this artwork
and stuff like that putin's actually
that's the real reason for this all poo
there's a couple picassos in ukraine
putin wants them back
the nazis still
um so i kind of feel like it's
relatively the same thing when it's just
about location and it's not even
like our country so my realtor always
says
location location location absolutely
i don't really understand
like if it's
dire and he's like unethical and just
like kills everybody and takes the spot
then i kind of understand but if it's
like you know basically
you know
the same kind of people and they speak
russian as well so
you know and then ukrainian and russian
are actually two different languages but
russian residencies and stuff like that
and like i saw no evidence of
you know war or anything like that no
there's definitely no evidence of war
happening right now yeah mingling and
not you know really
they're not
they're not healing
caesar or whatever
or apollo
or hitler
not that hitler's a god you know
like you can't really compare hitler and
apollo okay so anybody wondering uh
whitney's foreign policy take there it
is giovanni asking david do you think a
draft will happen if the u.s goes to war
no i don't um the the u.s military is
huge and uh biden has been clear no
boots on the ground
i don't i don't believe that that's
gonna happen
diana saying a family member of mine is
a special forces delta i'm so worried
i mean listen from what biden is saying
it
should be okay
should be okay what is this guy holding
up by the way look at this cost a dollar
to manufacture one this has been out 51
years what is that tell us about it
oh it's narcan until a few years ago the
police departments didn't even know
about it right when the first responders
always thought it was a larger syringe
overdosed
they weren't carrying it
she died on the way the hospital they
could have saved her life with this with
this right here it's the okay
um oh it goes in the nose oh oh oh okay
okay
got it
um stephen chapman says cpac man cover
cpac man oh i see that that's pretty
clever
it's pretty clever uh narcan is very
important to be very clear i'm not
minimizing it i don't exactly understand
what this interlude is at cpac
but um
we are of course very very supportive of
uh narcan
what what is going on here sheriff uh
we were talking about this over
prescribing david mentioned this with
his daughter
why is this such a a horrible critical
problem that we're seeing happening
where you have doctors over prescribing
individuals with opioids is this
changing based on more public awareness
that we've seen with the opioids crisis
okay very important issue we've done
interviews about it i don't know that
cpac is the place where
i necessarily
need to need to learn about that i guess
i guess i would say
i want to say thanks to lukan
for the twitch prime subscription very
much appreciate that and welcome to
everybody who is watching today is day
one of cpac we are also standing by for
jen saki it's just a huge huge day of
news and if
if you are just joining us i do want to
remind you
that the uh the big news
just in the last hour or two
is that uh the u.s now expects keeve to
fall
newsweek is saying in days bloomberg has
a source that says within hours kiev may
fall
three u.s officials have told newsweek
they expect ukraine's capital kiev to
fall to incoming russian forces within
days and the country's resistance to be
effectively neutralized soon thereafter
it is not yet clear whether vladimir
putin's plan is to annex all of ukraine
or whether his plan is to install a
puppet government
or we we just don't know we just don't
know what his plan is at this point in
time but that is the latest news and it
is tragic and it is horrifying and uh
the right is simultaneously telling us
this never would have happened under
trump but also putin's pretty cool for
doing it which is
confusing confusing to say the least
the phantom menace says via super chat
daddy david that's a little creepy i
don't like that i'm scared should i be
and what should i do stop drop and roll
well i have no idea where you are so
it's hard for me to say
jay dead says side question was there a
significant amount of separatists in
donetsk and luhansk someone told me many
people there wanted to separate i don't
buy it when i looked at
previous polling on wanting to leave
russia it is true
that one of the areas in rus in ukraine
wanting to leave ukraine for russia
rather
one of the areas in ukraine with the
highest percentage of people wanting to
separate
was that region
but it was still not a majority
still not a majority
important to mention
jody says happily upped my subscription
appreciate all the steaming yes if you
guys need any
seafood or clothing steamed
i will be doing it on air
very very soon i can steam uh
lobster you know whatever or
if you need clothing steam cleaned this
is really the stream for that
so i'm glad to have everybody here now i
understand just a typo but i appreciate
it jody very very much i really do um
do i believe that liz cheney would start
a new party instead of the republican
party no i don't think she has any
interest in that whatsoever
lucian says david sir do you think putin
will go beyond ukraine and moldova or
even nato countries like romania as a
romanian i am worried
i do not believe putin will try to push
into nato countries based on the
on everything i've read right now now
notice how i'm being careful with my
language like when people were talking
about hydroxychloroquine a long time ago
i never said
hydroxychloroquine definitively doesn't
work and never will be shown to work for
covid how could i possibly say that that
would be overstepping what i said was
there's no evidence right now that is
serious that
hydroxychloroquine works for covid so
similarly i think putin would be crazy
to push into nato countries
and i don't believe that he is likely to
do it based on everything i've read
but circumstances could change
and then i might
re i might revise
my position
okay
um
phantom menace says they're in the u.s
no i don't think you need to worry about
in the u.s right now i don't think so
not about this i mean there's plenty of
things to be worried about
in the u.s i just don't think bombs from
from russia are something right now
thanks to font t
for the twitch prime subscription you
were number 36 today very much
appreciate that we are about seven
minutes from the next speaker who will
be the wrongest man in the world on the
pandemic alex berenson
he said we need to stop all vaccination
right away right away we're going to be
hearing from him in a little bit we're
also standing by for joe biden's white
house press secretary jen saki
and we are also monitoring a number of
different uh feeds from around the world
here is live video in kiev where it is
now 11 24 p.m
uh looking at that
we have um this is
nbc news let's listen despite the fact
that he's saying he doesn't want to
occupy the country he's forced to and
then what does that mean and how
difficult does that turn out for russia
and president putin and that's just not
that's not to discount of course the
fact that they may be saying this and
not really meaning it
here a very long day a very long night
for you thank you so much for being with
us so often
you bet
all right let's go now to john herbs
former u.s ambassador ukraine and senior
director of the atlantic council's
eurasia center ambassador thank you for
being here with us president biden
issuing severe economic sanctions on
russia earlier this afternoon
how much could they hurt russia and what
role does diplomacy play at this point
because we know uh economic sanctions
don't just kick in immediately
well i think that vine put down some
very serious economic sanctions
a couple of days ago
i don't think what we were announced
today was that much bigger than we had
two days ago so i'm frankly a little bit
disappointed i think it needed to be
stronger
i understand the difficulties on
taking russia out of swift i don't
understand why they didn't move
specifically on the russian central bank
so you know putting out on background
they will do that hey does everybody can
anyone say for when i hear them talk
about swift i assume that they're
talking about not allowing russia to use
the swift system for bank transfers like
when we
send payments to people abroad like
let's say we work with a
a brand
that is based in some other country we
use banking swift codes it's almost like
a routing number but international is
that what they're talking about not
allowing russia to use that mechanism
okay okay that i wanted to make i didn't
want to mistake that
that's what they're talking about very
good they're not talking about the swift
boat veterans for peace no they're
talking about uh swift codes okay other
super chats coming in no there are no
other super chats coming in that's okay
i want to say thank you to the frog for
gifting a subscription via twitch your
number 37 also big shout out and thank
you to justin quickl justin quickl just
signed up at joinpakman.com
using today's new coupon code cpac trash
cpac trash
is the um
is the new
code
uh okay couple other things i wanted to
get to let me get my list over here
um
hold on a second so much happening today
people want one one more whitney
voicemail all right i can be convinced i
can be convinced
let me see here
at least whitney is on topic she's
mostly calling in about russia ukraine i
i appreciate that i mean at least it's
not about myers briggs anymore
so anyways i noticed that
um like the
the black men in my town are like
specifically like protective
over
um
over people
and
they don't like mixed races in my town
like both the white supremacists and
like the black black people
um they don't like
getting a little edgy let's move on to
something different
so um i did meet a lady from africa not
even gonna keep that that's a recipe for
disaster don't even want to hear another
word about it let's see if i can find
something a little bit safer
um
just something a lit just so we don't we
don't have a problem
because a lot of this a lot of this
material is very very borderline
in a number of different ways
maybe we'll just get away from this all
together i don't even think we need it
right now
yeah let's just let's just get away from
it other super chats coming in they are
talking about banning russians from
listening to taylor swift's albums
somehow i don't think that that's what
swift is about
you gotta add destroyed to your sound
board what is this reference what what
is destroyed is that something i said or
did someone else say destroyed
i don't remember that at all
nobody's sure yeah i don't remember what
that is
i apologize
i apologize i just don't know
mike pillow said it yeah i'm not sure
i'm not sure
um oh let's see if we can find
a feed that's live in the room with jen
saki
it looks like they're getting pretty
close
to
yeah here we go
i've got another feed
so we're monitoring both
cpac
and gensake
momentarily if you're just joining us uh
this is the first of three consecutive
days where we will be streaming cpac but
there's so many other things um going on
that we're we're covering as much of it
uh as much of it as i can taking a look
at the cpac agenda up next is alex
berenson the wrongest man in the world
on the pandemic then there's some kind
of round table with some candidates i
know carrie lake is particularly
radical
then the ceo of the nra will speak
obviously ted cruz will speak josh
hawley and then we will we will call it
uh for the day and tomorrow a number of
other speakers expected um
final thoughts here
whitney calls it's not right but it's
okay
exactly denver said what is your
myers-briggs personality type i have no
idea
i have no idea
big daddy says by putin and his
supporters logic are communities in the
u.s that mostly speak russian rightfully
part of russia well no this is like i
said imagine that mexico said hey you
know what there's all these people in in
texas and arizona they look like us
they speak our language they they mostly
prepare our food
they really are mexican so we're going
to recognize laredo and you know these
places we're going to recognize them as
independent places oh we got to send
troops in to defend them too by the way
nobody would accept that nobody would
accept that it's absurd
sam says do you think we should send
arms to ukraine and what other support
should we offer them we're already doing
it
we're already doing it
so there's no uh
you know should we be doing it
we're sort of jointly involved with nato
in defending ukraine in that way so
should really comes to whether we should
even be in those pacts right
the phantom menace with today's
most explosive super chat of the evening
uh
99.99 in all seriousness i love what you
do and what you represent here's some
money to make up for the loss of tulsi
supporters thank you phantom menace i
appreciate that
regards to russia and ukraine why now
why did putin choose this moment in time
to invade when he's held these
historical grievances for so long i
don't think there's any easy answer to
that but uh i am going to have a
commentary on that maybe on tomorrow's
show
bay photo says have you seen the
fascinating photo of ted cruz sitting
under a portrait of trump no no no it
was a portrait of me look at that it was
a portrait of me that they were sitting
under not trump
see if you look close closely it's
actually my face
that they were sitting under see that
it wasn't trump
no yeah it's a bizarre picture and uh it
was before it was photoshopped by one of
our viewers
it was uh it's very very cult-like
very very cult like it's all crazy and
of course of course ted cruz what does
he have a diet diet coke or something
like that
uh for some reason these guys always are
having a soda
maybe it's a beer i don't know i can't
tell what it is
but yeah i know i did see that i did see
that and it's pretty wacky
it's pretty full on weaponized
super chats are just pouring in
um david i'd be interested to see you
check out markets on predicted between
steaming sessions perhaps after the
seafood yes i'm going to steam some
lobster
and then we'll look at predicted now
let's let's see what people are betting
on predict it is interesting because it
just tells you kind of like where people
are what what bets people are placing
um let's see
what we have
markets
so let's see uh by not a huge margin
betores seem to believe trump will be
the republican nominee over desantis but
it's pretty close
for the next supreme court nominee the
vast majority of the money is be behind
judge brown jackson that that's i agree
with that
what else is interesting here
how many times
trump uh biden will mention russia or
putin during the state of the union 11
or more 60 cents
uh
a lot of these are not super interesting
almost no one believes trump will be
indicted by april 1st i agree with that
most people believe a supreme court
justice won't be confirmed by april 11
april 1st i absolutely agree with that
85 cents of every dollar are going to
biden and putin will not meet by july
1st
all right interesting yeah interesting
to some degree we'll we'll keep an eye
on uh where the money is so to speak
cpac alex berenson will be speaking very
soon the wrongest man in the world on
the pandemic
will there be a bingo for trump at cpac
maybe i might do bingo i i probably will
also do biden state of the union bingo i
think that that
could be an interesting thing to do
um i have a robo advisor that uses tax
loss harvesting if i don't sell is it
still a useful tool i i don't i don't
know you have to see how it's configured
uh very particular
to how the robo advisors are set up
thanks to leroy hotdog zanzibar the
spiffy canadian and irie man for the
twitch prime subscriptions i really
appreciate that i see a lot of con trump
is speaking saturday guys not today
trump is speaking saturday
for people who are
wondering what these toolsey
cancellations are what i'm referring to
is that the tulsi people have started to
cancel me they're trying to hurt us
financially here's robert who wrote in
earlier today and said david i have
unsubscribed
because you revealed your our tribal
tulsi gabbard speaks to citizens of all
labels
calling us to remember common ground is
far greater than pet peeves so robert
canceled
uh
his membership
and so in particular to fight these
toolsies
i would love it if you signed up on my
website joinpakman.com we set up a new
coupon code called cpac trash
you can use the code obama if you prefer
obama
but i suggest the coupon code cpac trash
as we stand by what do we think will
happen first alex berenson speaks or
gensake starts
you guys tell me what you think we're
monitoring both
i have a sense it's going to be berenson
i think something crazy is going on at
the white house and that's what's
delaying uh jen saki
that's my sense
of the situation
yeah you guys it seems like most people
in the audience agree with that
um do i have any normal voicemails about
the situation in russia yeah let's see
um
here's one david sir i was wondering if
you are familiar at all with
international relations theorist john
niersheimer yeah he basically
suggests that the ukraine crisis now the
ukraine war he's actually the west's
fault yep i'm not i'm not a fan of uh
meersheimer
and i think he's uh been often just
misguided in a number of different areas
so i i don't really uh i don't really
pay attention to him
um
oh wait a second this have they
completely changed the agenda the gordon
chang thing
the gordon chang thing was scheduled for
tomorrow morning it looks like the
schedule is all messed up
this is not even what was scheduled
right now
that's really weird yeah i don't know
what's going on guys this this was not
what we were promised
what's going on here
okay anyway the cpac speech seems to
have been completely unhinged they're
talking about ukraine russia let's see
what they're saying
the russians have captured chernobyl
just north of keith
and they've also got an air base
recently just south of the capital
but today we're going to start
with your outfit oh my god we're going
to talk about clothes can you believe
this where the world's going to pieces
and we're going to talk about clothes
yes gordon this morning you were in
emerald green yes and now you're in
yellow so what gives
well i don't know if anybody's looked at
the ukraine and we will ban
men
and so i've actually put this on because
i want to be in solidarity with the
ukrainian people okay well 48 hours all
right hey that's okay
that's something have their own nation
i'm okay with that
very soon ukraine will fall yes when you
were deputy national security adviser in
the trump administration
and when your team left office
the world was peaceful
now it's falling apart must be biden's
fault what accounts for this this is
just 13 months yeah you know okay so my
job in the trump administration is
deputy national security adviser that's
the person who comes up with the policy
the secretary of state the world's
diplomat he negotiates the treaties he's
the guy that the world sees
the national security adviser is the
person who's at the president's elbow at
every meeting everything that's going on
the deputy national security adviser is
the one that's supposed to sit back and
say okay what's the plan
and so the plan in the trump
administration was the central part of
the plan was energy all right not
exactly the riveting speakers we were
hoping for and something has happened
this this panel was supposed to be
tomorrow so i have no idea why these are
the people speaking right i just don't
know it's it's all very very strange but
any moment jen saki is doing a press
briefing and we're going to monitor that
industry says i understand you disagree
with glenn greenwald's politics but
grift implies you think he's a liar like
trump can you explain no i'm not totally
sure on greenwald i think he may be a
grifter who has kind of developed a
character for clicks and money
um or maybe he's just a very very wrong
person i'm still the jury is out on
greenwald
trump riding on a missile into russia
like dr like dr strangelove would be
classic says ryan right
right i want to say thank you to
anal garvey who just signed up with the
coupon code wow 22 at joinpackman.com
thank you very much
uh let's take so yes people are noticing
that the sake press briefing is like
humiliatingly delayed it was scheduled
for 3 p.m eastern originally
and no it was scheduled for like 1 p.m
eastern push back to 3 and technically
this is still the 3 p.m
press briefing that we're waiting on
even though it's now 4 40 p.m so
i assume it's complete and total chaos
at the white house given what's going on
in ukraine and speaking of which let's
monitor things still quiet in kiev
let's listen to what's happening on euro
news
and from berlin kate brady told us that
chancellor schultz is determined for
united western response
well of course uh the first step now is
for this new draft of of eu sanctions
that we're expecting to have confirmed
uh at least this evening anyway and so
it seems right now that schultz is still
very much keen to take a united response
with western allies with european other
eu nations and of course nato allies as
well but as we know sorry the wind's
picking up a little bit here in berlin
this evening um as we know
the nato
there are preparatory measures now um
underway uh for potential
deployment of
nato
response forces and of course germany
does in fact lead the nato task force in
lithuania right now there's about 950
bundeswehr troops there member troops
from germany's military and so we heard
earlier today from germany's defense
minister as well saying that the
bundeswehr germany's military is now on
a national alert but of course that
would be
a united response with nato allies
what still seems to be off the table
however is germany potentially sending
any uh kind of defensive weapons uh to
ukraine and that debate is rumbling
again at the moment and there is going
to be a special session
of parliament here on sunday and that is
going to be
of course debated in the bundestag this
week and we're also expecting to see
another speech as well from olaf schultz
himself on sunday
and kate we do of course appreciate you
for um defying the weather there um
let's go back to what uh shaw said then
so he's called very very windy as you
guys can see extremely strong wind
um and uh potentially also
uh
there could be rain and both would be
um a very very big problem surrounded by
water big water ocean water right
is everyone forgetting how trump and
tillerson gutted the state department
true
true
can putin be overthrowing because of
human rights violation or other
violation i i apologize i don't know
that i understand
the question
um
i'm not sure if you if you clarify i'd
be glad to
address that i think it's a
interesting topic although i don't fully
understand what you mean
um
i am expecting gensake to get many
questions about sanctions
the concern right now is that every day
there's an announcement of more
sanctions
but increasingly
analysts are saying
it's not really clear the sanctions are
accelerating as dramatically as the
rhetoric is meant to make it seem
so i think there will probably be some
questions for jen saki here specifically
about sanctions
i want to say thank you to zach ferguson
as well as laura johnson both just got
new memberships on my website really
appreciate you guys very very much also
ev8 flicks
has gotten a twitch prime subscription
via twitch
twitch prime subscriptions are on twitch
we have lost video from the press
briefing room
for some reason that is not totally
clear to me we'll go back to cpac just
momentarily here
um and we're we're back on cpac
uh
okay
no other super chats here to address
appreciate that oh we were doing we were
doing russia ukraine related
uh
voicemails yes
hi david my name is asher i'm a teacher
who's been working with a student
to
be monitoring the ukraine russia
conflict over the past month and a half
and he and i have been looking into all
of the former soviet republics to see
what's their status and what's been
happening and i was just wondering if
you wouldn't mind maybe doing a
run-through of where each of them stand
because from where i see it there's the
csto the military alignment which was
demonstrated in kazakhstan just last
month to be effective in quelling
anything also
ukrainian supporters in kazakhstan were
arrested very quietly
kyrgyzstan is very vocally supportive
for russia's action of course belarus is
hosting some of this to go on
can you please speak to how azerbaijan
signed the treaty just two days ago even
though the garland or karlbach has been
a breakaway region uh with the same kind
of principles at play
that's a great call i should prepare
such a rep obviously i can't just do it
off the cuff but i should prepare such a
report
for uh
at this point probably not for
tomorrow's show but maybe maybe for
monday i think that that's actually a
great uh
a great idea
let's see what else we have on russia
ukraine
hello david sir this is nelson from
chicago uh i was just curious since
russia invaded ukraine to us and other
nations have imposed sanctions on them
but that doesn't seem like it's doing
anything as russia continues to move
through ukraine yes uh please forgive my
ignorant tears i'm not very savvy in
this field uh but i had a couple
questions regarding russia and ukraine
as well as china and taiwan
um first off what sanctions do you think
has to be imposed to get putin to back
off and assuming they did back off do we
just lift those sanctions and things go
back to how they were or would the
sanctions stand and for how long yeah i
think you don't just
turn the sanctions off like that so
first of all
um the sanctions have to hit i mean
putin's inordinately wealthy
and uh it's going to be tough to really
hit putin in a way that will you know
make them poor or whatever
but you can you can really inconvenience
enough of putin's immediate oligarch
friends
that they would hopefully go to putin
and say you gotta you gotta stop you got
to stop
um
and i don't think you you cut the
sanctions quickly i think you have to
have a slow off ramp to you to the to
the sanctions
um
i see people talking about
it's known that putin's a germaphobe and
he's been kind of isolated
is it possible that he's kind of
delusional and paranoid as a result i
don't know it's mere speculation i have
no idea
uh
not inconceivable not inconceivable but
doug says david appreciate all you do my
brother-in-law whose army was moved from
romania to ukraine to assist with
refugees sad times very sad times
very sad times
well said other ukraine related
super chats
uh voicemails oh david um
i am just curious um
about your
estimation about the likelihood
that
due to
um
the
effects of
okay uh next one let's see here what
else do we have
uh
david do you hear that worrying in the
background you hear that little bit of
like extra thing i've got going in the
background well that's nothing compared
to your latest video
your beard is messy
it looks like the conflict that's going
on in ukraine
okay
um what else do we have serious
questions about
ukraine russia
let's see what we've got
uh
hello this is luke hughes
i had a question how likely is it do you
think
given all the washington propaganda
around the ukraine invasion
that they're going to be able to use
this to win the midterms and get trump
reelected
and with his authoritarian
hero worship
how likely would you think he's going to
be to try not to give up power again
um i actually sort of addressed this on
today's podcast with bill share who
joined us and i think the answer is we
just don't know
we just don't know yet
here's one more voicemail on ukraine
russia uh hi david um i'm a long-time
listener and i appreciate your analysis
so i had a question
that maybe you might have some insight
in regarding uh the current situation
with ukraine and sanctions on russia
if sanctions do increase on russia from
uh
the america and the european side
um is there a possibility that russia
could try to alleviate
um that financial or economic stress by
turning to
other areas of the world such as um
china or the middle east well i i think
they're going to find themselves quickly
overextended so i don't i don't know a
lot see the thing is a lot of these
things are just
it's just idle speculation right now
uh and i don't i don't
know how useful that is tristan says it
destroyed was from guilfoyle's speech
i swear it wasn't just me was it i
didn't hear her say destroyed but if she
did that's
terrific i would love that
another super chat i mean if he don't
follow rules can they take him out putin
uh i am not really
comfortable raising the idea of an
assassination i i mean listen
sometimes there are assassinations that
take place but i've not heard it
discussed and i think
i i don't know if you're talking about
like regime change type stuff i mean
that we're getting pretty aggressive
there i don't know that
it's feeling a little bit out of bounds
right now to go to that
thanks to greenman
who just resubscribed on twitch for 24
months also thanks to chocolatey
jackdaw and m nelly
four
additional people guys we're at 49
let's give away another item
next person to get a membership on my
website gets a free coffee mug hat shirt
hoodie or sweatshirt your choice we'll
send it anywhere in the world where
there is functioning mail
we probably can't get it to north korea
right now getting it to ukraine would be
tough but we will get it to you wherever
we can
even if you use a discount code today's
new code is cpac trash because we are
monitoring the trash at cpac but whoever
is number 50 on my website gets a free
item we will send it to you
jeffrey says david is hungary a member
of nato if it is could hungary being an
autocracy along with other former soviet
nations that are currently nato members
further compromise the situation with
russia invading ukraine i'll actually
show you all nato members
current nato members
here we go
okay
here are the current nato members 30
members
in 1949 there were 12 belgium canada
denmark france iceland italy luxembourg
netherlands norway portugal uk u.s
other member countries greece and turkey
germany spain czech republic hungary
poland bulgaria estonia latvia lithuania
romania slovakia slovenia
albania croatia montenegro north
macedonia those are the 30 members
okay
current nato members current nato
members
uh okay
moving along
how much you want to bet conservatives
who are okay with russia invading
ukraine won't be okay with china
invading taiwan if russia gets away with
it maybe it will embolden china i've
been saying that for weeks we actually
discussed that on today's bonus show oh
the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
find themselves is bad right
we talk about the taiwan china thing
and understand that there is a very
different economic
importance to taiwan globally than
ukraine
can't deny it
can't deny it it just it's a
dramatically different situation
uh
are they wrapping let's see i think it's
really important to you know we've
identified the problem we've talked
about potential solutions but i would
just emphasize to everybody here don't
wait for washington to come up with the
solutions they're not going to do it
they're all bought and paid for
the important thing will be what happens
at the state and local levels
and
one of the things that i that gives me
enormous confidence
is i once went on a jag and i was
reading abraham lincoln's diaries and
when he was a young man he wrote this is
abraham lincoln but before he was
anybody he wrote you know i was really
born at the wrong time
because all the great deeds have already
been done america's independence has
been won the constitution the
declaration of independence just sadly
there's nothing left to do
so fast forward abraham lincoln was
probably the most significant president
in american history oof
really really crazy stuff going on at
cpac talia says david i'm trying to buy
a house soon interest rates are getting
higher i saw an article saying russia
invading is going to slow down interest
rates but increase inflation i i don't
economic predictions are
sort of like opinions just every
everybody has one and
no
very few people are are
you know
if you find a house that's affordable
now
at an interest rate that's suitable
buy the house
that would be my advice if you don't
don't just buy the wrong house at the
wrong price
because
interest rates might go up
i that doesn't that doesn't seem logical
to me applejack says any talk of the
ukrainian russian war is irrelevant
until we hear what tulsi has to say
about it i know you're joking
but i did tweet the other day and a
bunch of people liked it
including by the way ben mankowitz's
brother josh mankowitz
where was my tweet
um
hold on where was it ah here it is
at such complicated and confusing
geopolitical times as these i often find
myself wondering what would tulsi think
and of course that was a joke
that wasn't for real
um
okay
david did you see zelensky speech to
russian citizens i did katya i did
and uh
i mean listen i
some people called it a pathetic speech
a weak speech
i think he was being
somewhat more realistic maybe than some
people would be in that situation
uh
it's a bad bad bad situation
thanks to king peasy
for the uh oh wait no i said hold on
hold on who's number 50 first i have to
go to number 50.
oh huge dump of memberships number 50 is
mataab gill
mataab gill is new member number 50.
mataab
you get a free item from our online
store email info davidpakman.com and let
me know what you'd like and we get it
we'll get it out to you i also want to
say thank you to shane dunn
josiah diekmann
jamie dotson
brian needham
adam baker
brett williams wow huge dumps of
memberships cash jeremy sarah officer
signing up
grim reaper and sherry ellison new
members
alan lopera andrea cooper
and hunter rupnic 13 new members hold on
50 plus 13.
3 plus 0 is 3 nothing to carry
5 plus 1 is 6. that puts us at 63.
really appreciate that also thank you to
bums fidelis
and king pz
for the twitch prime subscriptions
putting us at 65. the coupon code is
cpac trash cpac trash because we are
watching cpac i think you've had enough
of the garden kt show so on to the next
thank you see who's next thank you
thank you very
come much guys
thank you all
[Music]
man
it's a very awkward conference
cringy
all right so we'll see who's up next we
the schedule's been they've they've
abandoned the schedule i mean as i
showed you guys already um this gordon
chang thing was scheduled oh but no but
tomorrow it's a different topic let's
see
chang
is south korea the next venezuela but
that's tomorrow
more oh this oh they just moved it
around so that was scheduled for 350.
at this point i don't know who the hell
is speaking next guys it's the it's all
over the place it's completely all over
the place we'll just see i don't know
could be anybody
uh cantankerous l says even if russia
wins this battle they just guaranteed
themselves years and years of terrorism
from ukraine separatists putin is so
short-sighted maybe so
maybe so archer says david sir russia
has targeted ukraine with cyber attacks
today so is it conceivable they will
respond to sanctions with attacks on the
u.s yeah they're actually threatening
that already um uh we we have we had a
story on today's podcast
with exactly that uh there are threats
from russia that they will be um
responding to the sanctions it's funny
two days ago they said
it is
the sanctions are no big deal
and then yesterday they said the same
they said the sanctions are painful and
we're going to respond and cyber attacks
indeed
may be what we see
that very very much may be what we see
it's all speculative things are moving
very quickly
thanks to lambert fs for the twitch
prime subscription i appreciate you very
much
i think these i already read
yes i did
okay
uh let's do
a couple more voicemails
hi david
my question is
why when russia invades ukraine do we
apply sanctions and go into crisis mode
but when israel
invades palestine
by creating
vampiring rockets and bringing down
buildings we don't impose sanctions
and we don't criticize their government
we we do criticize their government the
situations could not possibly be less
analogous
um and i find those comparisons
i mean i hate to say they're just so
dumb uh it just
it's a completely different framework
it's not even
remotely close to the same thing and
typically people who bring that up fall
into one of two categories they don't
understand anything that's going on
or
they're kind of just bad faith actors
that really just want to criticize
israel
um so yeah i'm sure there are other
shows that will kind of give you
what you're looking for on that
but
this isn't one of them this isn't one of
them
okay
let's see who's next here
here is the wrongest man in the pandemic
alex berenson let's listen it looked
like his speech just fell out of his
pants did you guys see that that was
extraordinarily weird it literally
looked like he pulled it out of his
pants
[Applause]
uh thank you
um
i've sort of made my brand as uh
somebody who tells people things they
don't want to hear
so let me start you made your brand as a
guy who lies and is wrong about
everything um stop trying to ban books
okay
yeah this guy said 500 000 people would
not die of covet in the u.s we're at a
million so
this guy cannot be trusted on anything
rules or get it out of school libraries
or confessions of matt turner don't do
it if you like free speech if you stand
for free speech you have to stand for
free speech even if you don't like
what's being said
and that is what the left has completely
forgotten
more and more day by day week by week
censorship never works it always fails
it fails strategically because it tells
the people
you're competing with that your ideas
don't work by the way the guy advocating
for no limits on speech is the guy who
went on fox and said we must stop
vaccinating immediately the vaccines are
leading to deaths and are
counterproductive interested in it this
is famously called the streisand effect
it's always been true and it's more true
than ever
so
don't stand for censorship censorship is
un-american it's unconstitutional it's
wrong and besides the left is way ahead
on it the left loves it so let the left
have it right now
um
it's really amazing to me in the last
five years how far the left has gone on
censorship
most stunning
only two weeks ago the department of
homeland security put out a bulletin
where it defined terrorist threats
as misinformation or disinformation
about covid and election fraud and and i
want i want to read to you exactly what
the department of homeland security
defined as a terrorist threat two weeks
ago
if you make statements that and i quote
undermine public trust in government
institutions to encourage unrest
which could potentially
inspire acts of violence you may be a
terrorist okay i'm a terrorist by that
definition
and that means that the government is
entitled to do
lots of things to me if it actually
defines me that way okay
that is wrong and by the
way this definition could easily be
applied to plenty of people on the left
who spoke out in favor of the black
lives matter protests okay this is
dangerous to both sides it's dangerous
what a compelling speaker huh should
walk away from it and
journalists
should be asking about it but they don't
they don't want to because they're so
they're so in love with squelching
debate right now the people who i used
to work with at the new york times have
never said a word about this i find it
stunning and so disappointing
um
and you know across the border in canada
people who donated money to a protest
that was truly mostly peaceful
essentially entirely peaceful
had you know had threat were threatened
by the canadian government
that they would have you know their bank
accounts frozen that they would
essentially be shut out of life
for donating to a peaceful protest
that is suppression of speech it is
wrong
[Applause]
and one week ago
one week ago
people in the federal government spoke
out against a website called zero hedge
which had committed that website is nuts
that website is insane the biden
administration did not like it's a total
conspiracy loon website check it out on
source watch and rational wiki you're at
a very
strange moment when this stuff is
happening and you know yeah the strange
moment is that there's people who want
to paint themselves as legitimate saying
guys you should really get info from
zero hedge is also acting indirectly
through big tech which i know ron
desantis spoke about governor desantis
and i i felt like he was speaking to me
as he was talking about how big tech
censors because last year at this
convention i said hey twitter has been
good twitter has allowed me to speak
and you know i've i've said things about
the vaccines and i've said things about
covet that lies you know the mainstream
narrative uh it goes against they were
lies it goes against the mainstream
narrative and twitter's allowed me to do
that and then in july i said something
that anthony fauci didn't like and less
than a month later i was off twitter
wait a second you said something fouchy
didn't like
and
30 days later you got banned
clearly fouchy called and said ban this
guy
pulls groups sometimes with hundreds of
thousands of people uh
this has to stop
these companies have held themselves out
as public forums twitter jack dorsey who
was twitter's founder and
until very recently twitter's
chief executive said
under oath to the senate that twitter
was a public square this is not a public
square if when you make
if you have views that people don't how
do people like this find spouses that's
a good question in the chat do this
and
whether or not they can do it
constitutionally is a question hopefully
that the supreme court will eventually
get to decide
i've brought a lawsuit against them yeah
former president trump has brought a
lawsuit against them no one cares one of
these suits is going to get to the
supreme court and twitter may not like
the outcome you don't know that dude
because i'm not i'm not backing down
this looks like budget monk you guys
remember that tv show monk with tony
shalhoub this looks like budget monk
with an oversized suit more than me or
him or any one person it's about whether
these
huge incredibly important american
companies are going to live up to their
promises to allow free speech and open
debate
and they are not doing so
okay so
i have 30 seconds left
and and it's too long
and i hope
i hope next year please cry
when i'm back here speaking to you
you'll be able to see what i have to say
on twitter
okay yeah and i hope he's gonna sue his
way back onto twitter response to covid
and ukraine and everything else
on twitter and facebook and these
platforms they should live up to their
ideals they should live up to our
country's ideals and they should be open
platforms for free speech thank you
49 year old man's goal for the next year
is to get unbanned from twitter very
very big announcement at cpac
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen this is a power
play please welcome former alaska
commissioner kelly chewbacca
chewbacca oh my god
man this is this is wild
thank you this is a power play
kelly chewbacca
i'm born and raised in alaska
the woke leftist
tried to cancel me
before there was cancel culture right
when i was an outspoken conservative at
a liberal law school
the leftists posted death threats
against me in the student center
i'm against them cancel me
i won't be bullied i won't be silenced
and i won't be controlled right
[Applause]
but make no mistake
the radical progressives want to wipe
out diversity of thought no they don't
and a nation divided
will not stand
our founders created a government
designed to be
of the people
by the people and
for the people
government is supposed to function
like the seven referees of a football
field
they regulate the plays
and they call the fouls but right now
we have 700 referees on the field
and they're fouling us all over the
place
when government grows
freedom they're felling us
does she mean fouling very personal
my parents moved to alaska before i was
born to pursue an american dream
but life doesn't always go according to
plan
and they ended up becoming homeless but
my mom she got a job in the oil industry
and with that oil job they were proud to
fight their way into working class
america
yes
i'm proud of them too
i got to be the first in our family to
pursue a college education and then i
dedicated my career to public service
making government work
for the people
i'm an anti-swamp bureaucracy whisperer
i've exposed waste fraud and abuse
cut costs
and my favorite
held government insiders accountable
i was focused on my job my church my
amazing husband and being an alaskan mom
educating five kids during
covid yup
shout out to the parents
[Applause]
and then
senator lisa murkowski
you all could be alaskan
she cast the tie-breaking vote
to confirm the radical environmentalist
deb holland to be joel biden's interior
secretary
and with that single vote
murkowski killed
thousands of oil and gas jobs
just like the one my mom had
i felt it like a kick in the gut
i owe everything to alaska
and to all those alaskans who came
around my family to give us those
opportunities that we had
but lisa murkowski
well she owes everything to her dad i'd
speed it up if i could guys but it is
live senate seat when he was elected
governor
for the murkowskis it's a little bit
like the british royal family in the
same way that queen elizabeth is going
to hand on that crown to a descendant
the murkowskis have been handing down
our alaska senate seat like a birthright
for 41 years
but nepotism breeds a lack of realism
so murkowski she doesn't feel it
when she votes to confirm joe
biden's radical nominees like she's done
over ninety percent has joe biden
nominated anybody radical i mean it'd be
interesting if he no no if he actually
nominated a radical person it'd maybe be
interesting
officer
voting along with biden's radical agenda
and bernie sanders a majority of the
time which hurts alaskans and everyone
in this room she even voted for the
green new deal
you know the infrastructure bill for
people on twitch saying that i should be
streaming at multiple resolutions i
don't have any control over that
unfortunately um so if you're not seeing
multiple resolutions available that's a
twitch side thing you can switch to
youtube where you can control the
resolution if a bandwidth is an issue
[Applause]
and aren't we all excited
that come this november
we are going to block
bidens
business busting
border bungling crime cascading defense
decimating energy annihilating gun
grabbing gender jumbling liberty
loathing mandate militating parent
punishing police persecuting socially
supporting america obliterating agenda
and we will ban men
one person standing for that
two i guess
[Applause]
we have inherited a great country
because of veterans like my dad
and others who have paid a significant
cost
and they walk in the footsteps of those
who signed the declaration of
independence
and they pledged their lives
their fortunes and their sacred honor
i believe that to whom much is given
much
is expected
so i'm not standing on the
sidelines while
joe biden and lisa murkowski and their
woke leftist friends
continue to obliterate
the state and the country that i love
no no
i'm all in
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
and today
i'm inviting you
to be all in with me give her money
because it is time
for americans with courage and common
sense
to rise together
and lead us forward
inspirational huh i'm kelly chewbacca
and i'm for alaska
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay uh getting a little weird denver
with a good question good geopolitical
question could the conflict in europe
embolden kanye to invade pete davidson i
think that is something we should be
looking at very very strongly
there is definite potential
uh and i think that that does need to be
considered
okay um
jensaki is now
i don't know something like two hours
and two and a half hours late with her
press briefing but we're just continuing
to see what's happening over at cpac the
agenda is
this guy wasn't even supposed to speak
today i mean the the entire agenda i
thought we were waiting for ted cruz but
at this point who the hell knows it's
bizarre
written words of a young school teacher
making her way across the plains in 1893
america the beautiful
we are a beautiful country but our real
beauty is in the fact that we are a
beacon of freedom for the rest of the
world think about it america is the most
philanthropic country and is always the
first to arrive with disaster aid we
have 25 percent more foreign-born
citizens than any country in the world
we send missionaries to share the
message the gospel message of hope and
healing of christianity across the world
and we take in seems like a scam
preacher type guy huh a year that raised
their right hand to the oath and taken
allegiance to the constitution and we
celebrate that they are as much
americans as you and i do we believe
america is beautiful
yes we do hey listen
i'm not saying that we got it all right
day one right but america is exceptional
because we never quit trying until we
became the land of opportunity for every
american
a republic
if you can keep it ben franklin said
well
we are the longest lasting republic in
the history of the world do you believe
america is beautiful
that dang straight we do you just ask
freedom also has a price
gettysburg
guadalcanal
normandy
i would never forget standing on the
grounds and looking down out at omaha
beach and across the atlantic ocean
and realizing
that d-day wasn't won by great military
generals or superior air cover
no it was won by 18 and 19 year olds
that kept charging up that hill wave
after wave to make sure that those
freedoms would be passed down to another
generation ladies and gentlemen i ask
you today do you believe that america is
beautiful
absolutely we do
over the last few years
leftist radicals are better named
democrats in congress
they're no longer trying to hide their
motives it's all changed
their attack to erode our liberty is
supported by big tech the press and the
media
and now even corporate america has gone
woke
yeah this is a good question could it
mean anything that senators aren't
speaking at cpac and the press briefing
is so late yes yes
something seems to be going on
the uh the cpac agenda
included a speech by ted cruz right now
and a speech by josh hawley in 25
minutes
there was supposed to be a press
briefing starting
literally two and a half hours ago
there was a report that putin made maybe
hours from taking keefe
anything could be going on yeah i no i'm
i'm starting to get the sense that
something weird is going on as well it's
uh i i don't know what
but something something very well could
be going on
vote literally vote against sustaining
the life of a baby that somehow survives
a botched abortion
my friends that's evil
when joe biden and kamala harris give
the green light to illegals when they
know their children will be trafficked
and assaulted oh give me a break this
guy is trashed i can't this guy's just
disgusting let me hear from a couple of
you guys more voicemails are coming in
about um
uh russia and uh
and and ukraine let's see what else we
got going on here
uh
hello jackson it is bellavita here and i
just wanted to touch base with you about
lauren beauvert
and a couple of people who are a person
that's running against her
in the third professional district here
in colorado um
okay we're not doing that right now but
we are gonna we are gonna look into
those um
those races for sure
uh let's see what else we've got on
ukraine russia while we wait and figure
out what is going on
you saw your video about
kyle right now
and naturally i don't care troy with the
while you know calling while eating it's
just it's very very boring
how many
chelsea damper videos are you can do i
did two i did two tulsi gabbard videos i
did one tulsi gabbard video where i
explained that
she clearly is not on the left and she's
defending putin and i did a second video
about her speaking at cpac so the answer
is two troy two videos
two videos that's the number
uh do you think sweden will be attacked
because we are not a member of nato no i
do not believe russia is going to attack
sweden
this is so funny how this in many
how this and many other conservative
media outlets are bashing the left and
praising putin just after ukraine got
attacked by russia yes
senators are supposed to be getting a
briefing from national security blinking
etc
uh okay
wow they they are still not now they're
they're falling like over an hour behind
[Music]
i think this is another radical
candidate
should be a rare treat
[Music]
thank you thank you
how are we orlando
how great is it to live in the freest
state in america
[Music]
but we're only free because of
tremendous leadership by governor grand
desantis
the man who beat and defeat falci-ism
chose america first the same as
president trump did
when president trump stopped out
socialism and who is the true elected
not selected president of the united
states
[Music]
how many of you remember
when president trump was elected
when they talked about the fact that he
will be the beginning and start of world
war three
okay um we i did just find this report
this is interesting this could be an
explanation
as to why things are not happening that
should have happened uh take a listen
any of this exclusive reporting now from
nbc news president biden has been
presented with
options for massive cyber attacks
against russia in response to the
invasion of ukraine attacks could be at
a scale never before contemplated
interrupting power internet connectivity
even tampering with railroad switches in
russia joining us now nbc correspondent
ken delaney who broke can you imagine if
biden derailed trains in russia i mean
that just sounds crazy this new
reporting and msnbc national security
analyst clint watts ken first to you
bring us up to speed what is being
presented to the president we should
caution we don't know that he's signed
off on any of this but what is so
interesting
is that this would be in advance of any
attacks against us it would be offense
or defense if you will defense of
ukraine which was hit again with cyber
attacks this morning
that's exactly right andrea and that's
what's so significant here american
officials and others briefed on the
matter tell courtney qb and me that
these options include things like
shutting off the internet in parts or
all of russia disrupting uh
trains and railroads that are
resupplying uh russian troops in ukraine
uh everything from making the trains not
function to making them fall off the
tracks oh my god
these options are designed to disrupt
but not destroy we are told so they
would fall short of an act of war they
would be carried out by a variety of
agencies including u.s cyber command the
national security agency the cia would
be involved they're designed to be
deniable to be secret and the fact that
we're reporting on them sort of
underscores the complexity of all this
uh and and they are designed to strike
russia in in part in retaliation for
this invasion and in part to defend
ukraine and irrespective of whether
russia strikes back and the sources were
talking to us fully expect that russia
would retaliate with what they described
as colonial pipeline style attacks
designed to hurt american consumers they
are factoring that in and that's why in
fact there is a big debate within the
administration right now we are told
andrea there are some people who view
this as is really dangerous and
escalatory because both russia and the
united states have the ability to
destroy one another's critical
infrastructure in cyberspace and to turn
off the power things that would become
an act of war but there's another camp
that says why do we have all these cyber
weapons if not to use them in a way in a
situation like this where again not
designed to kill people but designed to
make russia pay a price in a way that
only cyber can wow they are looking at
things cyberly it appears
uh that is something that is something
um
wow
wow i don't even i'm gonna have to think
about that i don't i don't even know how
to react to that
uh if you're just joining us we were
scheduled to cover cpac from 3 45 to 5
45 eastern time
and by 5 45 we were supposed to have
already heard from senator ted cruz and
from senator josh hawley they are
missing the entire cpac agenda has been
mixed up and jumbled almost like a cake
batter
and um
uh
and you know things can get pretty crazy
with cake batter
and meanwhile
we we know that uh jensaki is often late
for press briefings but she is now
two and a half hours late for a press
briefing and so the natural question is
what is happening here
what is happening here
um
with reports from the last two hours
that keeve may only have hours before it
falls to putin
we just don't know what's going on
anything could be going on anything
could be going on
um i want to say thank you to oh tool
time for the twitch prime subscription
number 67 today
we are planning to stream every day
upcoming we have cpac going on and we
also have the russian invasion of
ukraine they are continuing look at this
at cpac to stuff other people not even
scheduled to speak if you look at the
schedule it was supposed to be cruised
10 minutes ago and holly 15 minutes from
now and that was going to be it
and yet they are bringing out all of
these
quite frankly sea listers
uh
wow
wow
um if you don't properly cream the
butter with the sugar the cake ends up
too dense yeah it's happened to all of
us it's happened to all of us it really
has
um so that listen we're trying to figure
it all out as as it goes on so what
we're going to do is
let's let's take cpac live right now as
we stand by for gensake and for the
scheduled uh stuff i'm gonna step away
for five minutes refill my water etc and
then we're gonna keep going
it was an oath to protect the
constitution against all enemies
foreign
and domestic
[Applause]
and right now
despite the mainstream media lies
and rhino cowardice in corruption
you know
and we know and we see the true nature
of the enemy that we are facing and the
fact the brutal fact is clear
the left is actively trying to destroy
our country
we know the truth
we'll let the word go forth this
afternoon from all of you who are
standing here that we are going to stand
for our country and we're ready to fight
for it
i've been down to the border
not just to texas into arizona but to
the mexican side of the border
and i've seen the six hundred thousand
two million people that are crossing our
border every single month
that is an act that is making america
weaker and our adversaries stronger they
are trying to destroy this country when
you look at what they have done with the
defund the police movement
and the horrific rise in murders around
this country they are trying to destroy
our country when you look at critical
race theory you can see they are trying
to divide our country when you look at
the coveted tyranny and the assault on
our liberties you can see that they are
trying to destroy our country when you
look at inflation when you look at the
military disasters
in places like afghanistan
and biden's policy of weakness and chaos
that leads to aggression like we're
seeing in the ukraine
you can see that they are trying to
destroy our country
and
and a lot of a lot of folks in the
mainstream media some rhinos they might
say well you know i mean this is just
because joe biden is senile and kamala
harris is incompetent
and that's true they are
but it's more than that but it's more
than that folks
no one is this stupid
no one leaves behind billions of dollars
of military equipment for the taliban
but that's what they did
and we must stand together to recognize
the nature of the enemy we are in a
fight for the soul of our country
and it is a battle against evil
it is a battle against cruelty and it is
a battle against tyranny and we have to
recognize that the left's policies are
rooted in cruelty
you go down to the border right now
joe biden and mexican drug gangs and
cartels are involved in the largest
human smuggling operation in history and
it's happening on our border and that is
cruel
we talked to one customs and border
patrol agent who told us about one kid
who'd been sold 17 times
you talk to the families the thousands
of families around this country who've
lost loved ones to violence because of
the left's insane defund the police
movement that is cruelty
you think about what's happening for
families who've had kids with
disabilities kept out of school for a
year that is cruelty
the left is cruel
and it is also tyrannical
you look at their assault on our
liberties their assault on the first
amendment their assault on the second
amendment
you look at the left's assault on our
elections and on election integrity
you look at what the left is doing
the way they now and we know they spied
on candidate trump and they spied on
president trump and we know the truth
and we see around the country
the george soros funded assault on the
rule of law
that's the nature of the enemy that we
are facing
and when you look back historically
what you see is the same thing that our
founding fathers saw
the nature of leftism is that it never
stops
they always progress to more and more
tyranny and you can look at the jacobins
in the french revolution you can look at
lenin and stalin you can look at mao in
china pol pot in cambodia those who ride
the tiger of tyranny
they keep progressing to more and more
oppression because they know that if
they step off the tiger will eat them as
well
so the fact is the left isn't going to
stop
and you have to make a choice
we have to make a choice are we going to
stop them
and i will tell you that right now we
know patriots around this country are
rising up and we're saying we are going
to stand for our country and we're going
to take it back
and this country will not be taken back
by rhinos
it will be taken back by america first
patriots who are willing to stand with
courage and faith to make sure that we
can pass on to our kids more than we
inherited there is a stark choice facing
our country at this moment
and it is a choice
between surrender
to leftist cruelty and tyranny
or
the revival of our republic
with freedom and faith and courage and i
am here to stand with you for the
revival thank you god bless you i
appreciate your courage thank you very
much
thank you
thank you
thank you
thank you
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen from the national
rifle association please welcome wayne
lapierre
[Music]
thank you very much
and thanks to all of you for being here
today
you know everywhere you're live so
here's nra's wayne lapierre the press
briefing's happening let's listen
spare bank and vtb
which together hold more than half of
the russian banking system's assets
over 750 billion dollars in total
for vtb we will freeze all of its assets
touching the u.s financial system and
prohibit u.s persons from doing any
business with the bank
for spare bank we will sever its access
to the u.s financial system
we'll also freeze the assets of and
prohibit any business dealings with
three additional russian banks with
combined assets of over 70 billion
dollars
we'll also restrict u.s investors from
providing debt or equity financing for
13 of the most critical
uh russian state-owned enterprises which
combined have estimated assets nearing
1.5 trillion dollars
and finally we'll also impose sanctions
on the executives at these state-owned
institutions
as well as additional russian elites who
were complicit in putin's kleptocracy
and their family members
those who've shared in the kremlin's
corrupt gains and stored their wealth in
yachts and luxury condos and fancy cars
will now share in the pain of these
measures wow
in terms of the financial impact as i
said these are the most impactful and
significant sanctions
the u.s has ever taken
but financial sanctions are just one
part of our response we're also
unveiling today an expansive and
unprecedented set of export restrictions
developed in historically close
coordination
with the european union australia japan
canada new zealand the united kingdom
and taiwan
these new measures include sweeping
restrictions on russian military end
users to impair putin's military
capabilities
and will also deny exports across russia
to sensitive cutting-edge technology
primarily targeting russia's defense
aerospace and maritime sectors
in total the united states and our
partners will effectively be cutting off
more than half
of all high-tech imports going into
russia
this includes curbing russia's access to
advanced semiconductors and other
foundational technologies that russia
needs to diversify and modernize its
economy
working in tandem these financial
sanctions and the export controls
will undercut putin's aspirations to
project power on the world stage
and those impacts intensified
dramatically just today the russian
stock market plunged over 30 at one
point
before being halted by local regulators
russia's currency the ruble weakened to
its weakest value on record against the
dollar
before the central bank
intervened and the price the market is
charging the russian government
to borrow
is now above 15 percent
these impacts over time will translate
into higher inflation higher interest
rates lower purchasing power lower
investment lower productive capacity
lower growth
i want to interrupt only because there
are starting to be reports and we have
to see
whether they are trustworthy there are
starting to be reports
that a russian platoon has surrendered
to ukraine in the north
and that ukraine has taken back control
of antonov airport near kiev
um
it's this is very early but ukraine did
issue a call saying anybody who's
able-bodied come help
and there are multiple reports that we
are trying to confirm
that ukraine has taken back the airport
which would be a major major uh success
if if true we're monitoring allow for an
orderly transition of these flows away
from sanctioned institutions
and we provided other licenses to
provide for an orderly wind down of
business
let me just stop there and take your
questions
i just had a real quick question you
said it would take some time
before it affects the
economy inflation what's the timetable
how long do you think it will take until
you have demonstrable results
well look
these are these are costs that build
over time and as i mentioned i think
last friday
any leader whether you're an autocrat or
a small d democrat has to pay attention
to the living standards
uh of your country
and uh already
we're seeing the effects of these
measures and the signaling that we
provided yeah let's go back to cpac for
a bit i guess wayne lapierre is losing
his mind we're sneaking into his shop
and secretly buying guns
this is one of the most disgusting
characters in american politics right
now
and the next day they go out and rail
against you and me and our second
amendment rights
you know when you think about it maybe
that's why so many celebrities are out
there pushing so hard for mask mandates
they don't want anyone to recognize it
when they sneak into the gun store
and if any of those hollywood hypocrites
are watching right now as we sit here
i have a message for you
no matter how much you attack us
belittle us or try to shame us for
exercising our second amendment rights
the men and women of the national rifle
association will fight for your right to
keep and bear arms just as hard as we
fight for ours
because this freedom belongs to all of
us as americans
and even though we're facing off against
the anti-gun white house nancy pelosi
and charles schumer
i'm proud to report that nra
isn't just holding the line for freedom
we're advancing it every time joe biden
has tried to ram through his gun ban
agenda through congress yeah this guy's
vile all right let's get back to the
questions here's uh that could be
mentioned but let me let me say this
i think today was a demonstration that
we mean what we say
we delivered on what we said we would do
in terms of imposing costs so when we
say all options are on the table
and that we're prepared to continue to
ratchet costs higher
it would be a mistake to doubt that
resolve
but let me let me also step back and say
that when we consider which sanctions to
apply
we're not cowboys and cowgirls pressing
a button to impose costs we follow a set
of principles we want the sanctions to
be
impactful enough to demonstrate our
resolve and to show that we have the
capacity to deliver overwhelming costs
to russia that's one
number two we want them to be
responsible to avoid even the perception
of targeting the average russian
civilian
and of course unwanted spillovers back
to the us or the global economy
number three we want to stay coordinated
uh and so we calibrate our sanctions to
maximize the chance that we move in
lockstep with our allies and partners
number four they should be flexible so
that we can escalate or de-escalate
depending on uh
backs on the ground and lastly as i
mentioned before they have to be
sustainable these sanctions work over
the long term that's what will guide our
design in light of the sanctions that
were announced against individuals and
entities let's see if we can go here
instead with our allies and partners
number four they should be flexible so
that we can we might be able to see the
reporters on this feed
backs on the ground and lastly as i
mentioned before they have to be
sustainable these sanctions work over
the long term that's what will guide our
design
in light of the sanctions that were
announced against individuals and
entities in belarus can you tell us
whether there are sanctions against any
other countries that are being
seriously considered at the moment and
what is the line that a nation would
need to cross in this conflict for them
to
receive be on the receiving end of
sanctions from the u.s well the belarus
measures were about delivering costs to
a country that aided and embedded what
we saw uh yesterday and overnight but i
have nothing else for you in terms of
other countries being
targeted oh do you have a question oh
yeah yeah definitely i know i didn't
mean i was not using the arms here
thank you we'll come back to you
i wanted to ask you about the some of
the carve outs uh there are general
licenses for more than a dozen areas
agriculture energy and you just said uh
that the importance is to limit the
impact on americans but i was hoping
that you could say
is there a percentage that you can share
of the number of exemptions that make up
the overall transactions so the general
licenses
how many how many trans what percentage
of the transactions are under those
licenses
i i would refer you to treasury nofak
for the for the details on what what
exactly uh is being exempted and the
percentage of business that would be
included i mean could you say is it a
third is it a half i mean is it a small
percentage is it a high percentage i
would go back to the the principles of
our design
the measures themselves and the
exemptions are balanced so that we can
deliver overwhelming costs
while not having unintended consequences
and so that's the that's the principle
but as to the specifics i'd refer you to
treasury wouldn't the oil be a large
percentage i mean considering how
important it is to
uh to russia's bottom line
well look um where we have an asymmetric
advantage is in foreign capital and
cutting edge technology
so that's where we're that's where we're
delivering the most concentrated impact
when it comes to energy
this is the one area
this is the one area where russia has
systemic importance in the global
economy we know it's the second largest
natural gas producer in the world it's
also the second largest crude oil
produced in the world
that's not to say that we have a
dependence on russia russia depends on
those revenues just as much as the world
needs its energy but we're not going to
we're not going to do anything which
causes an unintended disruption to the
flow of energy as the global economic
recovery is still underway
thanks two quick questions
one if putin takes key does that trigger
additional sanctions specifically that
scenario
uh not going to speculate on particular
hypotheticals
you mentioned the timeline you've been
asked about the timeline the president
said in one of the answers to his
questions today is at least okay
conversation in a month so it is now ted
cruz this was the main point of the
stream so let's listen this is uh the
most weaponized moment of cpac day one
god bless cpac
it's already bad
[Applause]
what an amazing sight
thousands of patriots
and not a damn mask in sight
and we will ban men
what a horrible person
everyone here is just following stacey
abrams example
a lot of empty seats huh
we find ourselves at an existential
moment for our nation
the
threats in our country have never been
greater
so i want to do something a little bit
unusual for cpac tell the truth
i want to step back
and go a little more philosophical oh
okay
and ask what is
this battle all about
what are we fighting about in this
nation
and i'm going to suggest that the
fundamental conflict that is playing out
across this great nation
is a battle between power
and liberty i disagree that's not what
it's about the two are in fundamental
conflict
we are seeing it every day
vaccine mandates
versus doctors and nurses
i'm getting charles manson vibes anybody
else
versus kids in school
spotify
versus joe rogan
go fund me
versus canadian truckers
justin trudeau
[Applause]
[Music]
let's pause for a second and observe
that is the first time in recorded
history
that any canadian has ever elicited that
much of a response from any crowd on
planet earth
justin trudeau
[Applause]
and the god-fearing canadian truckers
[Applause]
the new york times versus barry weiss
barry or white levi's
versus jennifer say what a stupid sound
[ __ ]
aoc
versus damn near anyone who ever dared
to criticize her
[Music]
did he just fart did you guys hear that
or was it just me who heard that it
means you really want to date her
[Music]
if you look at this battle
this is not a battle between
the weak and the strong
joe rogan is many things but he ain't
weak oh my god
major league baseball
which went after the voters of georgia
the georgia voters are many things
but they ain't weak
the biden department of justice when
they went after parents
[Music]
parents are many things
but they ain't weak
just ask loudoun county
just ask terry mcauliffe
just ask all the left-wing democrats in
virginia who are scared out of their
minds right now
you got to understand what is playing
out here what is playing out is the
powerful
are afraid
they are terrified
of you
they look out at the men and women in
this room and you scare the living crap
out of them
yes but not for the reason ted cruz
thinks afraid of truth
they are afraid of liberty
that fear is driving them let me suggest
a principle
a very simple principle for
conservatives to understand big
is bad
across the board big government sucks
big business sucks
big tech big hollywood big universities
any accumulation of power
that is centralized
is fundamentally dangerous for
individual liberty
what is it that the communists want the
communists want control of everything
they want centralized power what
communist is he talking about there's
none here in the us barely
as i'm talking about
were said far more eloquently far more
elegantly
two centuries ago by james madison and
federalist 10.
james madison talked about factions
that was an old word for special
interest
and he said factions if they're able to
seize control of government
will strip away our liberty
and the genius of our constitution all
right some people demanding we go back
to gensake but let's let's wait until
she actually takes some questions
makes the executive and congress fight
makes congress in the judiciary fight
makes the federal government in the
states fight and what the framers their
genius was
yeah the supreme court has called it
splitting the atom of sovereignty
and that if the factions
if one faction can't seize control of
everything you guys think five or ten
percent of the audience even has any
idea what he's talking about five or ten
percent or less oh it's true today
why is our liberty so under assault
because giant corporations giant tech
giant government they work together hand
in hand five okay
two oh wow you look at what happened
with joe rogan joe rogan jen saki
oh come on jen saki doesn't get the
justin trudeau treatment
[Applause]
you know peppermint patty deserves some
love
[Applause]
oh boy
jen sake from the white house podium
said uh billionaires oh billionaires in
silicon valley
please silence that pesky rogan guy
there's a pattern of government
asking big tech to silence dissent
in canada the canadian truckers
canadian government says oh gofundme
billionaires
please silence these pesky
truckers by the way
the workers of the world had a revolt
and the left is pissed
all right let's listen to jen saki for a
bit okay a couple of things at the top
for all of you uh one usaid put out an
announcement that they've deployed a
dart or disaster assistance response
team to respond to humanitarian needs in
ukraine
this star team which is currently based
in poland is working closely with
european allies and partners who will be
on the front lines of the response the
team will lead the us government's
humanitarian response to help address
critical needs caused by russia's
invasion of ukraine the dark comprises
17 disaster experts from usaid who are
assessing the situation identifying
priority needs to scale up assistance
inside ukraine and working with partners
to provide rapidly needed assistance to
communities affected by the conflict i
know a number of you have also asked me
and we've tried to provide as much
detail as possible about how the
president has spent his time over the
last period since last evening i think
we put out a few details but just to
reiterate for all of you
he closely monitored the events on the
ground
from both the oval office and then back
in the residence over the course of last
evening we put out a few details last
night including the fact that he spoke
repeatedly with his national security
adviser jake sullivan he also spoke with
his u.s u.n ambassador linda thomas
greenfield before she gave that powerful
speech at the u.n last night he received
a briefing from
secretary austin chairman milly
secretary blinken and his national
security adviser around 11 pm
approximately last evening as well and
as you know he also spoke with president
zielinski he continued to monitor
closely into the wee hours last night
this morning as you all know he engaged
or he met for
just about an hour with his national
security team which included
both a full table in the room and full
members from from the cabinet from the
national security team on the screen
during that meeting as a standard he
received an update from of course
defense intel his diplomatic team about
the status on the ground and he has of
course remained closely engaged with
them through the course of the day as
you know he also had a g7 meeting that
lasted a couple of hours this morning
sounds like a lot of work guys hour this
afternoon on the phone with the uh
leaders leaders in congress democratic
and republican leaders in congress
briefing them on the situation on a
secure call briefing them on the
situation on the ground answering
questions they had as well
so that has been his day to date and he
is continuing of course to focus on
other priorities as president but why
don't we go to you zeke thanks uh jen
sticking up on that has president made
any additional foreign leader calls
today has he spoken to the president
zelinski um since their
caller saving there's not been another
call to president zielinski i expect as
you have seen over the past several days
he will continue to have calls with
leaders we will keep you abreast as
those happen and with the us government
saying that it believes that the russian
objective right now is to
decapitate the ukrainian government does
this us believe that president zlensky
at this moment is safe
uh we're not going to get into security
uh security questions but we are in
touch with president zielenski and we
are there's a real question about if and
when zolensky has to leave the country
in addition to calling for uh the west
to improve to cut russia off from swift
and also proposed uh or called fort
demanded i think where he was going to
tweet um that the us uh and its allies
impose a new fly zone over ukraine i
know the president has said that he
won't put u.s boots on the ground in
ukraine to fight russia is is ukrainian
airspace
is ukrainian airspace uh in play is that
something that isn't
subjected to any discussions we've
certainly seen i've seen we've certainly
seen his uh his tweet uh or his request
via tweet uh but i don't have an update
on that request that's not
off the table with no presents now
again i i don't have any updated on this
point in time or status of the
discussions go ahead thanks just a
follow-up on troops faster than a few
cyber questions
do you expect nato to call up a major
response force and how many u.s troops
could be called to help in that effort
that's really up to nato as you know we
have a number of troops thousands of
troops that are on call but that is a
decision to made by the nato alliance
the president said if putin pursues
cyber attacks against our companies our
critical infrastructure we are prepared
to respond so just clarifying does that
first mean that there has not been any
evidence of any cyber attack from russia
against any american companies at this
point
not that we have identified or
attributed at this point in time and can
you i mean aside from past ones that you
were fully tracking yeah i guess i mean
yeah 24 i understand
can you explain more of the white
house's thinking on kind of this debate
in washington about whether a cyber
attack against a nato ally would trigger
an article 5 response a response from
the alliance
that again is up to the nato alliance to
determine but obviously a cyber attack
does constitute an attack so that would
certainly be a point of discussion among
the nato members okay one more really
fast on the us usaid disaster my
response you just mentioned a 17 person
team
is that enough we were talking about
we've heard you guys talk about
potential of hundreds of thousands of
years and i think that's an important
point but what i what we're trying to do
here is provide any incremental update
on the status of what our work is and
i'll just note and you may be fully
aware of this but in terms of
humanitarian assistance
we have been the biggest provider of
humanitarian assistance ukraine we've
provided over 52 million dollars in
humanitarian assistance to ukraine in
the past year over the past few weeks
we've committed additional funding and
supplies to humanitarian organizations
there's been a specific need and
therefore a focus on support services
food clean water hygiene shelter trauma
primary health care our prepare and we
are prepared to certainly provide a
significant amount more so this is just
one step obviously less than 24 hours
after the events of last night and we
will continue to plus up from here go
ahead
there are a number of protests within
russia itself are you monitoring this
what's your message to them
well uh there certainly are and i know
with everything going on this may not
have caught everybody's attention but
let me just
note that
you know today we're seeing russian
people in the streets open letters from
leading russian journalists
and cultural figures denouncing
president putin's war of choice and
reports of russian mothers concerned
about the reckless deployment of their
sons to this fratricidal war i think
it's important to remember back in 2014
when they didn't even acknowledge that
they were sending russian soldiers they
didn't even acknowledge when there were
body bags coming back from ukraine into
russia and there is an outcry
in the streets by russian people
by by more russian people than i think
many would expect so despite putin's
crackdown at home dissenting views
remain and i think that's important to
note to publicly protest against
president putin and his war is a deeply
courageous act their actions show the
world that despite the kremlin's
propaganda there are russian people who
profoundly disagree with what he is
doing in ukraine one more speaker pelosi
is talking about sending 600 million
dollars in lethal aid to ukraine is this
something you support
we are in uh conversations uh with uh
congress and i mentioned the president
spoke with leaders uh just earlier this
afternoon i don't have an exact number
but those are ongoing conversations
about what needs the ukrainians have on
the ground in a variety of categories
security humanitarian other economic
assistance go ahead does the u.s have
any analysis to indicate that there is
dissent or division within putin's
government or is it your understanding
that putin's government is united in
this war it's an interesting question
and jamie without getting into
intelligence which obviously we look at
i mentioned obviously russians
protesting in the streets that's not
exactly what you asked about but if you
watched uh the meeting the president
president putin had uh with
members of his national security team
the other day it was quite striking the
back and forth he had with his intel
chief in that meeting and
the the analysis of that is certainly
can be done in an open source manner
given it was quite public but i will
leave outside analysis to uh to give
further assessment of that and and as
you know uh we are seeing ukrainians
start to flee the country is the u.s
prepared to accept ukrainian refugees we
are but we we certainly expect that most
if not the majority will want to go to
europe in neighboring countries so we
are also working with european countries
on what the needs are where there is uh
capacity at poland for example where we
are seeing a an increasing
flow of refugees over the last 24 hours
or through its flow of individuals i
should say out of ukraine what their
needs are and we've been talking and
engaging with europeans about that for
some time now part of what you're doing
is to prepare for the united states to
accept the president is certainly
prepared for that but i would just note
that because uh there are a number of
european countries neighboring ukraine
who have expressed an openness to it and
we would anticipate many of them would
want would want to go to european
countries and just one more quick
question uh the president of course has
repeatedly said that american troops
will not enter ukraine is there any
scenario that's been discussed where
that decision might be reconsidered
the president has no intention of
sending uh us troops to fight in ukraine
that has not changed go ahead
um this was asked the president earlier
but i don't think
i want to briefly interrupt because
there are two bits of breaking news that
i want to present to you just to keep
everybody apprised first of all
ukrainian president solenski has said
the enemies sabotage or sabotage forces
if you prefer william shatner's
pronunciation have entered the capital
me and my family are remaining that's
from 16 minutes ago that is number one
bit of news
number two
is the following report
cnn citing ukrainian intelligence large
bombardment of kiev expected around 3
a.m that's in 2 hours and 20 minutes in
other words 8 p east
3a
ukraine is when um
that is expected and so far that type of
intelligence
has been accurate has been accurate that
have been ongoing for some time since
the beginning of the administration to
harden um the private sector work the
with the private sector in partnership
to harden their cyber security
protections we've actually seen a great
deal of progress made in the financial
sector it's it's one of the stronger
sectors in terms of protections from a
cyber front that we see out there so
it's been ongoing for several months um
obviously when there are moments like
this where we continue to watch and look
for what the potential is uh we will we
continue to to engage closely with a
range of industries about what they need
to do about the potential threats and
that's something that happens obviously
privately and through a range of
agencies i can see if there's anything
more specific that we can read out to
all just real just real quick one follow
uh
president biden said they are that the
u.s is prepared if an attack
he said prepared to respond would that
response be a cyber attack
yes yes would that be an equivalent
cyber attack against russia
well i would say that uh the president
reserves the option uh to respond in any
manner of his choosing uh overt or
covert um uh seen or unseen as we like
to say in more available english um but
i'm not gonna get into specifics of what
that looks like uh he has a range of
options go ahead it would be crazy to
get into oil prices and spr does the
administration have an oil price in mind
that would trigger another release from
the spr i think not that we're going to
get into detail or from here do we want
to go to josh hawley who's today's
keynote speaker at cpac or stick with
the questions here a little bit is that
what has been ongoing both from the
president who's been very engaged in
this uh having conversations with
leaders in the middle east and other
parts of the world as well as many
members of his national security team
here okay whatever steps we can to
mitigate uh the impact on the global oil
markets uh and obviously that means
increasing supply obviously we'll check
out a little bit of the strategic
petroleum reserve would be part of that
but in terms of what that looks like or
the specifics i'm just not in a position
to get into more details at this point
thanks if the worst happens and russia
either
reduces the flow of natural gas or cuts
off energy altogether to europe does the
administration have a good idea for how
long
households in europe could last under
that kind of circumstance i i don't have
an assessment of that um from here i can
certainly check with our economic team
one thing i will say that one of the
steps we've been taking obviously
natural gas shortages and supply is it
is an enormous regional issue one that
would hugely impact europe more than
here of course one of the steps we've
been focused on and been taking is
engaging with
partners who have who may have
excess
lng supply like countries in europe
japan for example where they had where
we would were planning to give them some
and now they're going to divert it to
europe um so we've been working to um to
help mitigate um any impact of a further
invasion and a shortage in europe
go ahead some of the activity that we've
seen today in ukraine some of the
clashes had been in and around chernobyl
does the united states have an
assessment of the risk of a radioactive
release
so i do have one actual update on that
as well there's also been there was also
a
report out so let me speak to this first
just so i don't forget um about um
passages uh around there as well so let
me speak to that first
we are outraged by credit credible
reports that russian soldiers are
currently holding the staff of the
chernobyl facilities hostage this
unlawful and dangerous hostage taking
which could upend the routine civil
service efforts required to maintain and
protect
the nuclear waste facilities is
obviously incredibly alarming and
greatly concerning concerning we condemn
it and we request their release in terms
of a further assessment i don't have
anything more on that from here you gave
a read out of how the president spent
the past 24 hours or so
first i wanted to ask about his call
with president zolensky did he indicate
if he was still in kiev did he identify
his just tweeted he's in kiev
we are aware of where uh he is located
um and we are in touch with him i would
say on that call uh what uh what um they
discussed is uh president zielinski's uh
request for the president to be uh to
condemn the actions of president putin
and the russians and to engage with
other global leaders about it and that's
exactly what he's done we've seen a
number of statements today from former
presidents uh president obama president
bush also saw former president trump on
television talking about this has the
president you mentioned
during the afghanistan drawn out he had
been in contact with his predecessors
has he been in touch with any of his
predecessors during this he has not been
today and then in terms of another
domestic priority that was potentially
included in his meetings today uh given
the situation his time and focus and
attention on the supreme court uh excuse
me on ukraine will this affect the
timing of his supreme court announcement
uh we we are still on track to make an
announcement before the end of the month
we have to do a lot of things around
here at the same time go ahead uh just
to follow up on the cyber attacks and
article five questions i know you said
that it's up to nato to decide but from
a u.s perspective uh would any cyber
attack against a nato ally trigger
article five or would there be a measure
for what what counts yeah that's the
conversation we would have with our nato
allies and partners i had one that was
about
and just to follow up on the supreme
court um and you said you're on on track
but has he made a final decision given
there are basically two days
left uh for the end of the month uh not
a not a final final uh no offer has been
no job offer has been made
go ahead thanks uh just a couple um are
there any concerns or indications at
this point that russia had prepared for
the sanctions that you're putting in
place and kind of develop preemptively
ways to want that impact
well it's an interesting question and
it's and some of it is is hard because
it's hard to get into the minds of
president putin and the oligarchs around
him uh one of the steps let's listen to
a little bit of holly because i did sort
of promise i'm covering cpac and he's
today's keynote let's listen to just a
little bit
will you pledge to stop it
from being taught from being promulgated
in the united states government
and the answer is no
they're radical on this issue they
believe in critical race theory they
believe that america is systemically
racist they believe that america is
systemically broken
they believe that we're a nation of
oppressors
it it's very stupid yeah it's it's not
even worth it you know the ruble is the
worst performing currency in the world
right now uh their inflation is has
skyrocketed uh so we're even seeing in
their markets the anticipated impact
even before today and that's even before
the actual squeeze on uh on the
financial sector uh in the country uh so
it it feels to me it would be a little
hard to plan around and plot around
given the significance of what was done
today and the fact that um when we
sanctioning ten 10 of russia's financial
institutions and these export control
measures which essentially cuts
president putin off from semiconductors
and access to a range of technology he
wants for the future uh those are
difficult things to uh plan ahead for i
guess secondly um does he mention have
any assessment for how china is reacting
to this at this point whether they are
willing to provide support to russia how
much and has there been any kind of
contact there to kind of attempt to move
them off of any support well
in terms of what impact they can have i
mean china uh only accounts for about 15
percent of china and russia i'm not sure
you can double check me on this about 15
of the global economy if you look at g7
partners in the us and europe it's about
50 right so they cannot cover
uh what the impact of the sanctions that
have been announced in coordination with
europe would how they would impact
russia you know i think from our
perspective as it relates to china well
i can't get into the heads of of what
they're thinking is you know this is a
really a moment for china for any
country to think about what side of
history they want to stand on here um
and you know that is certainly the the
the case that something tells me china's
thinking a lot about taiwan right now
that secretary blinken spoke with his
counterpart just a couple of days ago uh
you know the president's certainly open
to speaking with his counterpart but i
don't have any prediction of that at
this point in time or a timeline go
ahead thanks jen over the past couple
weeks as you've been sending the alarm
on this you've
put the sanctions package together done
conducted the diplomacy with the
russians and the rest of the world um
how did the ukrainian government use
that time
since they've been initially warned that
this was
a likelihood did they use that time
wisely to prepare
tell me more about what you mean exactly
well uh you're seeing reports from uh uh
the streets in russia of i'm sorry in
ukraine of people being surprised uh you
had obviously local and national
leadership in ukraine
uh
telling people to stay calm tournament
to go to work even the day before
the invasion began so
were they properly prepared and was
there more that they could have done
uh in the leader look i think it's not
particularly constructive for us to give
an assessment of that uh what uh what i
can tell you is that our focus has been
on providing up-to-date uh what has
turned out to be quite accurate and
transparent information about what the
president putin has was preparing to do
which is invade ukraine and we have been
very clear with american citizens who
are there we have been clear with our
european partners uh four months now uh
including ukrainian leadership uh so
that has been what our focus has been um
and you know we will remain a strong
support supporter and partner of
president zilensky and ukraine moving
forward go ahead thanks chad um
following up on the sanctioned question
yeah uh we have heard for for weeks that
these sanctions were at least in part a
part of a strategy that was based on
deterrence as well as prevention
today with the president's comment that
no one expected the sanctions to prevent
anything from happening moving forward
do you expect this slate of sanctions to
prevent any further advancement or
aggression from russia well i would say
that later in the later in the back and
forth or the press avail he also said
when asked
if sanctions cannot stop president putin
what penalty can and he said i didn't
say sanctions couldn't stop him which
leads me to believe that's not exactly
what he meant he also went on to say the
threat of sanctions and imposing the
sanctions and seeing the effect of
sanctions are two different things and
the way we look at this broadly speaking
and delete touch on this a little bit is
that we do see them as having a
deterrent impact right it doesn't mean
they're 100 foolproof but if you um if
there's a 95 percent chance of russia
invading without the threat of sanctions
and there's a 60 i'm making up these
percentages just to make a point but uh
and a 65 chance uh that they will with
them you're obviously going to go with
the threat of sanctions because you want
to reduce the threat of an invasion so
there is a deterrent we've seen at the
deterrent impact work at times right
i'd also note that we are very
clear-eyed about the fact that president
putin not just a few days ago i mean he
gave the speech a few days ago where he
questioned the legitimacy of ukraine as
a sovereign country he's also talked
about how the breakup of the soviet
union was the worst thing that's
happened that's a paraphrase um in
recent uh you know in decades of history
so we are clear-eyed about his ambition
but what the other part of it that we
are quite focused on is the consequences
and the way we see it is you know as
we've touched on a little bit
inflation's skyrocketing the ruble is
the worst performing currency in the
world it was his decision to go to war
it's our choice to make him pay a price
same with the global community and we
believe these consequences are also
going to have an impact
just at the risk of repeating a question
as well i mean the president did also
say you know let's check in in a month
and there has been some questions about
time here it seems like this is a
strategy to use these sanctions to put
pressure on russia to eventually
discourage them to pull up or to force
them to pull out this this advance so
what is the timetable here you think for
when the russian government will start
actually feeling the impact of these
sanctions and possibly pull out well in
many senses they're already feeling the
impact i mean they said we're
threatening to attack u.s assets because
of the pain of the sanctions yesterday
so um in terms of how putin will feel
the the impact we just sanctioned a
range of oligarchs around him we
sanctioned 10 financial institutions um
these are all
these are all significant um in enormous
steps that are going to have an impact
on him but in terms of the moment by
moment i can't give you an assessment of
that
just uh there's been a lot of questions
about refugees in the region for
ukrainians that are in the country as
the u.s especially after yesterday
considering tps or any sort of
protections sure as you know that's a
decision that would be made through an
interagency process led by the
department of homeland security um and i
don't have any prediction of that i mean
i don't have any kind of prediction of
that at this point in time obviously
these these events are just unfolding as
we speak process hasn't started that
conversation i'm not going to give you
any specifics on an internal process but
i would just say again it's an
interagency process and right now uh
we're of course in the middle of an
invasion and uh and a uh you know a war
in uh in ukraine go ahead thanks jen
earlier you had said uh you have to do a
lot of things at the same time one of
those things of course is the state of
the union next year yes can you tell us
how the president this week has been
preparing for that how much time he
spent on this state of mind and how he's
juggling that with this very busy
schedule that you laid out earlier
tonight yeah absolutely um so in
addition to obviously uh being very
closely engaged and leading the effort
uh on the u.s response
to the russia to russia the russian
military invasion of ukraine the
president has been
working with speech writers working with
members of his policy team to finalize
details of his state of the union
doing starting to do some read-throughs
not too many yet i expect those will
increase in the days ahead i expect we
won't have too much of a preview for you
maybe tomorrow but maybe more likely
this weekend
he's also been
engaging with his covet team
talking about where we are in the state
of the pandemic what's next in the
pandemic he's been working closely with
his economic team on and receiving
updates on the supply chain the
implementation of the infrastructure
bill so even as we have all been
understandably focused on the conflict
in ukraine the president has been very
hard at work on a range of issues that
are vital to the american people we
touched on my follow-up abc is reporting
the white house is revamping the covid
strategy now that hospitalizations are
on the decline should we expect the
president to roll that out in the speech
next tuesday i don't have any uh preview
for you on timeline or format
but the president has been working and
engaged with his cova team
for some time now uh and we're making
strong trung progress
on uh moving toward a time when covet is
no longer a crisis the cova team has
been spending a lot of time and energy
including with the president working
with experts inside and outside
government local public health officials
and governors uh and this work is
broader than one piece of guidance how
we look at it is we're preparing to stay
ahead of the virus protecting our most
vulnerable keeping our country open
and that is and that is going to look at
everything from the cdc is obviously
reviewing mass guidance but also
how we're going to ensure that vaccines
boosters tests treatments
and other us and other important
components of our medicine cabinet are
available to the american people go
ahead
thank you i had a couple of questions
sure nobody next good
thanks a couple of questions first a
follow-up about some of the humanitarian
needs you've been talking about you've
talked about just a reminder i will be
live for the state of the union tuesday
will start an hour before the speech i i
am very much interested in seeing what
is in that speech um and i'm not
surprised jen saki's not giving too much
of a preview but we'll be live for that
we do have
fortunately or unfortunately a fair
amount of experience on providing
humanitarian assistance in
conflict zones and we typically work in
usaid specifically has a great deal of
experience
with that working with trusted third
party
entities obviously the government which
remains in power um so there's a range
of ways that we would provide assistance
in terms of other mechanisms i don't
have anything to predict for you at this
point in time and then another question
for you and this has been happening why
you've been up at the podium okay
i'm not trying to ambush you but i
wanted to give you a chance to respond
um senator ted cruz is speaking at cpac
and you came up he
he called you quote unquote peppermint
patty and has encouraged people to
don't tell him i like peppermint patty
so i'm not gonna take it too offensively
senator cruz i like peppermint patty
i'm a little tougher than that but there
you go go ahead hi yeah so um back to
the president's comments earlier today
so he did say to give it a month to see
if these sanctions work however you know
under russia's current assault ukraine
clearly might not have a month or even a
week so is it fair to say that he is
conceding ukraine to to poop
there's nothing about the president's
strategy or approach or leadership in
the world is the peppermint patty thing
an anti-redhead thing because i'm
looking at peppermint patty and it
doesn't look like peppermint patty was
even like a redhead i don't know
president putin uh that that's that
suggests that he is succeeding anything
um you saw him lay out a set of uh of uh
of historic uh sanctions today that will
maximize pain on russia yes uh as we've
as we've conveyed they're meant to have
a squeeze over the course of time but
we're already seeing an impact on the
financial markets on the currency on
inflation in russia and there is a there
are unfortunately the russian people are
going to feel the pain of that so i
would say the president is going to
continue as he has for weeks now to work
in close lockstep with european partners
to continue to press uh to press uh from
the global community uh for
it's almost like painfully stupid
peppermint patty i mean give me a break
dude president zielenski is in danger of
being killed or captured and put on some
sort of a show trial would president
biden send
u.s troops in on a rescue mission to get
him out
again we are in touch with president
zielinski who is an important partner we
support him who he is the leader of
ukraine governor the president of
ukraine uh but i'm not going to get into
security steps okay um there's this talk
about a possible forecast for financial
pain particularly the gas pump yeah for
americans um the president said today
the notion that this is going to last
for a long time is highly unlikely
would he try to ensure that by lifting
some of the restrictions that he's put
in place on the energy industry like
what we're rethinking some projects like
the keystone pipeline
well first of all the keystone pipeline
is not flowing so i'm not sure how that
would solve anything there's also plenty
of oil leases that are not being tapped
into by oil companies so you should talk
to them about that and why
but what the president's talking about
is we certainly understand and he said
this today right may have been in
response to your question i don't
remember but um if there's an invasion
of another country by a big country
there's going to be impacts on the
markets right and we certainly
anticipated that and we anticipate that
as it relates to the global oil market
as well so that's why the president for
weeks now has been engaging with a range
of big global suppliers some in the
middle east others to
see what we can do to ensure their
supply out there in the market to reduce
the impact on the american people and
the us is one of the russian oil
industries best customers hundreds of
thousands of barrels per day would the
president ever consider ordering u.s
companies to stop importing russian oil
i don't have any prediction of that at
this point peter we announced some
significant sanctions uh today uh our
objective is to uh in to ensure there is
the greatest economic pain on russia and
not on the russian people but on
president putin and to
minimize the impact on the american
people including companies here in the
united states
all right thanks everyone see you
tomorrow
and try to expand back the soviet union
so is this do you all think this is act
one in a multiple country invasion well
i'm not going to make a prediction of
that but we certainly think he has
grander ambitions
does he believe that president putin is
going to absorb ukraine into russia when
he says that president putin wants to
reestablish the soviet union is that
what he's saying i think he believes
that as we all do that president putin
has more has grander ambitions in
ukraine hence the military
campaign is continuing thanks everyone
i like this super chat question do you
ever listen to your crazy voicemails and
think this is what my life has come to
yes but in a positive way that i don't
have like a normal job with a boss and
you know a schedule and somebody going
we start at five after here and you got
in at ten after today and we're going to
need you to come in and follow up on
that and are you punching in and out
exactly when you take your break so yes
it does make me consider that but only
in the best way that is the end of the
press briefing
cpacs
have ended for the day we will be back
tomorrow i believe 1 45 pm eastern
we will be back
tomorrow
thank you very much see everybody soon
oh and thanks to our new twitch
followers twitch followers thank you to
every single one of
you you